according to a new report an Insider in
Moscow was claiming that Vladimir
Putin's already tried to detonate a nuke
but top brass are sabotaging him I don't
know how much I believe it it's really
excellent propaganda for the West if if
we're talking about sending more weapons
and resources to Ukraine the threat of
nuclear war certainly might get people
riled up but we'll see I mean you got to
choose what you who you trust in these
reports and that's why I'm careful I'm
saying this is what an Insider is
claiming take it with a grain of salt
however another report came out
on TV member of top brass in Russia said
that Kiev is planning an attack on a dam
and now Daily Mail is reporting this is
evidence that Russia is planning a false
flag attack so
sort through it how you can sort through
it both sides are obviously going to be
accusing each other but you know I'll
put it this way I don't trust Vladimir
Putin
I don't trust a whole lot of people in
this one so that's what makes it so hard
fog of War as Luke's t-shirt says truth
is the first casualty in war so we'll
talk about that and we've also got AOC
getting heckled at uh it was like a town
hall thing she was doing and this is
like the second time I think we've seen
the past week where her own constituents
are getting angry they're protesting
crime one guy stood up and said a 911
first responder was attacked what does
she do she starts dancing sticks out her
tongue while they're chanting that she's
gotta go
I think she's losing her grit and then
Elon Musk says he's gonna fire 75
percent of Twitter employees once he
takes over so we're all we're all really
excited for that before we get started
my friends head over to timcast.com
become a member if you want to support
our work as a member you'll get access
to the exclusive uncensored shows we put
those up Monday through Thursday at 11
p.m I will stress tonight we aren't
going to have one because unfortunately
we don't have enough time but I want to
make sure you guys were aware but uh
supporting our work directly allows our
journalists to keep working you'll also
get access to cast castle and the tales
from the inverted world show so it's a
whole lot of fun so don't forget to
smash that like button subscribe to this
Channel and share the share with your
friends be the notification you want to
see in the world many people have said
that YouTube is not notifying them of
the show YouTube is not letting people
know when The Show Goes live and for
some people they need it if you share
the video you can help us bypass that
censorship now joining us to talk about
all of this and a whole lot more is
Senator Doug mastriano oh yeah thanks
for having me on looking forward to the
show yeah yeah yeah who are you can you
wanna so I'm a senator in Pennsylvania I
have a Gettysburg and Chambersburg and
Hanover and Shippensburg in my district
I've run him to be the next governor of
Pennsylvania and served most of my adult
life in uniform in the United States
Army the 30 years started off on the
Cold War and the Iron Curtain with my
wife Reby who's here with us and
you know what after our initial training
we shipped off to Nuremberg Germany with
the second Calvary regiment
and patrolled the East German and
Czechoslovakian borders defending
against that kind of uh system and ideas
and oppression that are now creeping
into American society oh yeah and Robbie
and I remember the wall coming down and
and how the people in the East were just
excited to be free finally he was
amazing well we got to make sure that
doesn't happen here every day I'm
passionate because we did see we did see
the flip of that yeah people coming out
of it people being separated by that
wall from their families for 40 years
and it was pretty it was pretty
oppressive over there even on the free
side right we saw a big difference we
moved back to Germany after the wall had
come down and big difference in just the
whole you know feel of the nation and
the culture there so you know Robbie
would you like to introduce yourself yes
I am Doug's wife Robbie Rebecca go by
rebby and um hoping to be the first lady
in Pennsylvania so we can we can get
things in in order
instead of having all the um
left agenda moving forward in our state
we we need most of the pennsylvanians do
not believe that way and so we want to
stand for the people I hear you all
right well thank you both for hanging
out with us it's gonna be a whole lot of
fun we also got the T-shirt vendor
himself I was actually on the other side
of that wall my family was a part of the
side of the garden movement so I know
exactly what you guys are talking about
my name's lucridowski here of we are
change.org and I come here to you with
one simple message people will forget
your words people will forget your
actions but no one will forget that you
voted for Joe Biden and that's what
reads on my t-shirt which you could get
on thebestpoliticalshirts.com and it's a
great one to start conversations it's a
long-winded one and you either get one
of two reactions one is someone laughing
high-fiving you or just utter disdain
and shocked by some individuals and I
love having those moments you want to
have those moments get the shirt on
thebestpoliticalshirts.com because you
do I'm here thank you so much for having
me and I just want to add too I mean
you're walking down the street I see
this all the time with you Luke people
will be like hey brother I love your
shirt you know how I5 you meet people
that's that's right that's a way to
build a community a way to make friends
and a way to start conversations and
spread messages that can't be censored
there's a lot of things that may be
censored make fun of people who voted
for Joe Biden tons of friends who
thought yeah
hey buddy it's Ian Crossland here at Ian
crossland.net let's just keep this ball
rolling what's up Doug hey Rebecca
and I'm sir.com flipping switches
pushing buttons you know how it is there
you go all right let's jump into this
first story from timcast.com Putin has
already attempted to detonate a nuke was
stopped by sabotage Insider says Russian
expert believes senior level officials
are working against Putin to prevent
nuclear detonations in Ukraine a Moscow
Insider has claimed that Russian
President Vladimir Putin recently
attempted to detonate a nuclear weapon
but that his efforts were sabotaged by
top brass at the Kremlin the report
published at the mirror also says
unspecified technical issues could
account for the failure of Russian nukes
in recent weeks unspecified well of
course this could only mean one thing
aliens because that's because that's the
conspiracy theory that whenever you know
like the aliens shut down the news
there's actually people actually talk
about I don't know I don't know why they
think that's true we I mentioned this
briefly before the show I said I think
it absolves Humanity of responsibility
and that's why people want to believe it
the reality is
I'll put it this way
yo world leaders they're not above you
if you sit down in if you're in a bar
you wouldn't even realize you're talking
to someone because people are just
people you go into the courts you meet
politicians you meet enough people you
meet people who are wealthy and own
things and you realize everybody sort of
Acts the exact same way obviously people
know different things people have access
to different things but what I'm trying
to say here with this is
when you're when your neighbor got angry
at you over some petty BS that same
level of emotion can happen with someone
like Putin who's got his finger over the
button do you think this story is true
Doug I really don't buy it I don't have
any idea what Putin would have to
Advantage himself by detonating a nuke I
mean obviously he's talk I'm the
defender of Putin actually designed
strategies to defend their allies in
Eastern and Northern Europe against him
I don't want him in the Baltic Nations I
don't want him in Poland Etc but uh he
needs to talk about nukes as a
deterrence against the U.S and NATO
obviously a red line for him was a 2014
of course when a new government came in
it was pro-west pro-eu Pro NATO we've
seen a similar situation in 2008 of
course with Georgia
uh Georgia was bucking real hard and
working real hard to get NATO membership
and vladder was like Oh no you're not so
he swept in in AB kazia South assessia
in Georgia and waged that that war
achieved his objectives had a buffer
zone and then stopped this I have to say
I'm pleasantly surprised by the actions
of the Ukrainian Armed Forces just who
would have known that they would be able
to stop Vladimir Putin actually have a
counter-offensive yeah well they were
trading since 2014 U.S Special
Operations were down there trading every
single one of them and preparing the
landscape and when you're an invading
Army you don't have the advantage they
have home territory and they have all
the latest and greatest U.S technology
now I actually read this article and
this article is all over the place
number one the mirror doesn't have the
best reputation and they say in the
article quote Insider claims the launch
was uh was was not done because of
technical failure or by reluctant
military Chiefs so again who's the
source who's telling you these stories
and and number two you can't even get
the story correct which one is it the
mirrorism certified Luke so yeah it says
it's good and another thing to
understand here there is a chain of
command specifically with Russia when it
comes to launching nuclear weapons that
people should know about because it's
not just Vladimir Putin pressing his
finger on the button uh he also uh in in
Russia they also have something that's
sort of similar like the nuclear
football but they have a briefcase that
essentially notifies the general staff
the general staff have access to the
launch codes then after the general
staff get the launch codes they could
give it to individual weapons commanders
then they of course execute the
procedure then they send the nuke so
that's the protocol that's the chain of
command that they have in Russia which I
think is is also important to understand
here it's not just one guy pressing the
button and there are ways that the chain
of command the general staff or the
individual commanders could say no this
is crazy and and that's a likely
scenario here okay but how about this
Putin leaked the story on purpose to
scare people in the west to think that
he's actively prepared and wants to use
nukes you know what I mean like saber
rattle to the extreme there is Merit to
that we listen to any of his major
speeches and usually something about
nukes comes up or through a proxy of his
and so yes that's his deterrent model
much as Saddam Hussein you know I was
part of the Desert Storm Liberty in
Kuwait you know a war for energy by the
way and we knew that
but then Saddam Hussein got rid of his
chemical biological weapons didn't tell
the west but he kept talking about he's
going to use them against us as a
deterrent so I do believe that that's a
possibility Putin wants us to know that
if we take it to the next level there's
a high danger that it's going to
escalate what do you think uh you know
I'm not asking because I haven't read a
lot about this or that the audience
doesn't have an idea but I'm curious
your thoughts why do you think Putin
decided to invade Ukraine and why is
this happening
liner Putin has a bunch of problems on
his hands first off he's a single
commodity country basically it's oil and
gas a few years ago with seven 70
billion dollars a year now it's over 100
billion sanks of the gas prices
um a couple issues though Ukraine has
been drawing closer and closer to the EU
and NATO and the United States the
government is very Pro since 2014.
when most of these troubles began he
also has a population problem in that
his demographics are shrinking as far as
ethnic European Russians I'm not talking
about the Asians that make up most of
his country and and that demographic he
would like to have them in my studies
within a sphere of influence I think the
most vulnerable place in Europe other
than Ukraine is a Eastern labia dagger
pills when I visited there some years
ago I did not feel safe and I was there
in civilian clothes with a Danish buddy
of mine and uh it's like 90 percent
ethnic Russian and most of the Russians
there stayed as as a result of the Cold
War being stationed there their former
their dads were military members or
Intel officials and they're receiving a
stipend from Moscow by the way as well
about up to a thousand dollars a month
to live the Russian citizens they're
there the latvians who are ethnic Russia
yeah things don't look very promising
for the Russian Empire and population
decline is another major factor and now
with this war that that only has been
exacerbated that much uh worse it's a
Petro State Ukraine is also going to
challenge them specifically with the
national resources that they have the
gas that they have specifically in the
regions that Vladimir Putin now is
occupying inside of Ukraine so there's a
lot of things happening behind the
scenes there's of course NATO and their
influence and them being on their border
there's of course the sphere of
influence that Russia wants to still
maintain in this specific region and
it's a back and forth Challenge and I
think it was a desperate move as a
desperate situation and it's it's it's
it's a crazy situation that's only going
to get crazier from here and he needed a
decisive knockout blown that first week
and when when the Russian aerosol and
Airborne units came into the airport
outside of Kiev those were those are
Putin's best forces there's two armies
in Russia that I call you have to
specially trained highly motivated ones
like the Airborne Special Forces air
assault and then you have the arrest and
the rest right now you're seeing being
grinded down by the ukrainians when they
were beaten back that was a clear sign
that Putin was in trouble this would be
a longer track yeah I remember seeing
that seeing them land in the airport
inside of Kiev and then not hearing
anything else about them because they
weren't nowhere to be found and I'm like
that doesn't really make sense this
looks like
it's about buffer States you probably
look you said it it's a buffer because
Napoleon and the Germans and two Wars
and what have you when um when the first
attempt to go into grozny in the
caucuses and the Russians were beaten
back and eventually came back with
overwhelming force and I don't think
Putin has that leeway though right now
do you think it's reasonable uh in the
in the sense of an Armistice for Eastern
Ukraine to be split between the
ukrainians and the Russians those
freeways that go into Crimea I think
that's ultimately the goal is to take
those freeways to turn Crimea into and
Sebastopol into a trade Hub but do you
think that's reasonable for Ukraine and
Russia to share those freeways to each
take one and then or neutralize the
territory in some sense are you saying
like the Eastern region goes to Russia
or make it neutral or or that just the
freeway from the Don bass there's two of
them and one of them could be Ukrainian
one of them could be Russian
so the land bridge that you're
describing in is exactly what Vladimir
Putin needed and I think actually his
idea of driving that land bridge East
I'm sorry West towards uh the
transnistra which is a breakaway
Republican on the Ukrainian Romanian
borders I think he wants to have a a
broader pro-russian area underneath his
grass it does remind me a bit analogies
historically are dangerous but sedate
and land 1938
Czechoslovakia Germans there in
Czechoslovakia and of course I'm gonna
go in and the bad guy Hitler goes in and
liberates liberates quote unquote and
we're seeing a similar thing but the
problem with Putin has is the resolve of
the West I mean how many billions of
dollars of American money has gone in
there at least a hundred on the books I
mean well there's secret budgets and
then there's public budgets the public
budget is around 60 to 80 to 100 people
guesstimate right now but the the house
right now is talking about doing another
60 billion uh Bill specifically just for
Ukraine that's a lot of money and you
think about the Germans are so proud
because they came out and they announced
they're giving two billion dollars to
the UK Iranians to fight the Russians
but the Dirty Little Secret is is
they're paying two billion dollars a
month for Russian oil and gas the
hypocrisy you know when Trump in 20
remember in 2018 in the U.N Trump gave a
speech and lectured the Germans about
real life and they they were laughing at
him and mocking him who's laughing now
yeah yeah not the uh working class in
this country who are looking at their
gas tanks going we we hit what was it
five something a gallon it went down now
it's going back up California it's eight
bucks in some parts for the Germans who
are told prepare not to take hot showers
this winter because of energy costs did
you hear this the BBC is preparing
scripts for when they have to announce
the blackouts in the UK that was that
was the guardian we talked about that
the other day do you see any resolution
to this because all I'm seeing is
escalation escalation obviously the
winter is going to stop a lot of the
fighting but Putin is kind of posturing
like he might launch another Invasion
from the north of Belarus right now uh
all I see is escalations do you see any
way that this could possibly de-escalate
I know Putin said he's open to
negotiations during the upcoming G20
meeting do you think that's going to be
successful I viewed a Russian broadcast
last night that was talking about how
there's going to be no operations this
winter I think there probably will be
but it'll be minor I see no off-ramp
this year yeah what do you think an
off-ramp would look like a negotiated
piece um but it's going to have to be
the United States this is a hard thing
to say do you tell Ukraine to give up
you know Ukrainian territory you know
what the sad thing is and well is it sad
1994 the Bucharest treaty remember that
that Ukraine was like the third largest
nuclear power in the world at the time
that's right and and the United States
Russia and Great Britain Province the
defender borders if they'd give up the
nukes and they gave up the nukes and
who's defending their borders that's the
problem we have and Russia promised not
to invade them if they gave the nukes
and then and then here we are and the
problem with this is it sends a signal
to every country build nukes as fast as
possible or else exactly that's that's
nightmarish that's what the uh the
Indian general staff after the desert
storm in 1991 and that was my first
combat experience there they did a study
in 92 saying we have to get nukes to
prevent this kind of attack on us from
any country not specifically the United
States
they're the Bread Basket of Europe
they're you know and they have a long
tumultuous history they're I called them
the Afghanistan of Europe because when
you look at all the violence all the
bloodsheds specifically in Ukraine it is
a major Clash point and people were
kidding themselves not to see this as an
upcoming major proxy war that's
happening right now and you know I I
could only hope it de-escalates but I
think this could even last a decade I
think it could even last more than that
especially with the way that these wars
are fought especially with how close the
people are especially how there's
there's neighbors fighting against each
other which is atrocious which is
absolutely horrible I think we should
try to stop it but but at the same time
I don't see it stopping anytime soon
you'd have to Ukraine would have to
sacrifice the Eastern region they'd have
to give that up it's unless you know
Putin just eventually gives up but I
think Putin Canon will use nukes I'll be
at I don't have nearly the military
expertise you do uh Senator but my
concern is that Putin is he's
ideological and he's um
he's looking at the end of the great
Russian Empire of what Russia is I don't
I don't see him just eventually going
like well you know we lost this one I
think he looks at it like we will be
great we will never back down under no
circumstances if he loses in Ukraine
he's done right and you know you hear
Rumblings now I don't think it's is as
viable as Western you know comment
commentators are saying because he's
been very successful in eliminating
opposition around him the past you know
two decades actually he's actually the
longest uh ruler since is ours at this
point here I mean it's incredible uh
Ukraine I mean wow if they can push
through this winter here and then have
time to re-arm and refit and retrain
with all this new equipment and this
money hopefully that's going through the
battlefield I mean they might be they'll
start putting the Russians back but then
what do you do Vladimir Putin when your
armies are pushed out and that might
happen or buy small ones I mean can they
afford to buy eastern Ukraine is it cost
them 300 billion dollars
well this is why the Chinese have a
weird kind of situation on their hands
here because they they're a big trading
partner with Ukraine they have a lot of
relations with Ukraine but at the same
time they're still geopolitically
opposed against the United States so
this is a very weird situation for them
they're kind of like one foot in one
foot out but I think they're also a
country that we should be looking at
right now especially when it comes to
Taiwan especially when it comes to the
bigger geopolitical picture especially
with bricks and the petrodollar in
question with Saudi Arabia let me let me
let me pull up this uh next story real
quick and we'll get back into it from
The Daily Mail Russia plans false flag
attack on hydroelectric Dam to flood
Curson in latest attack on energy plants
as Ukraine brings in four hour blackouts
to tackle electricity shortages so
that's bad now what they're saying is
General Sergey seraviken Russia's new
supreme commander in Ukraine has spoken
to Russian media in recent days but we
call the devastating strike on the Nova
kakovka Dam which he said was being
plotted by kev's troops Sarah vikan who
has also been preparing the Russian
public for a retreat from the region
said the blast would flood Kirsten and
cause widespread damage they go into
mention in the article that according to
experts from the study of War it's
actually them prepping us to accept a
false flag attack because what's really
happening is they're saying hey look
they're going to attack us then they
blow the dam knocking out power in the
region retreating and then blaming
Ukraine for it who do you believe
yeah that's you go ahead you want to say
something before
you know I've studied Russia and the
Soviet Union and now Russia for 30 some
years and that they're they think half
European and half asian I mean in their
foot like you said actually in both
camps it's just like kind of like with
China I mean they are sometimes Oriental
in their thinking uh in the end for
Putin it's about his survival his power
base and after that was better for his
vision for Russia yeah I covered this
story uh in my earlier video today on my
channel and it's the United States and
U.S Intel saying Russia is going to
launch a false flag attack to flood this
Russia is saying the same thing on their
state television and everything they're
saying is almost the same exact thing
except you reverse the major actors here
they're saying the United States is
going to be launching a false flag
attempt and we've seen this kind of
rhetoric heat up especially today which
uh you know is concerning to to say the
least but uh Anything could happen I
think we should always be skeptical but
when it comes to this larger War we have
to understand that there's also
unconventional warfare what happened to
nordstream wasn't an accident and I
think we have to look at our
infrastructure as as it's also a
potential Target for the Russians or the
Chinese or even third parties that could
intervene and say hey it could be in our
interest to spark up this conflict make
it a bigger conflict and it might not
even be Russia or the United States that
could set up a false flag it could be a
third party uh a country or another
special group that comes in there and
it's like okay fight each other as we
rise to power so obviously the concern
is as a humanitarian crisis so we have
the deeper Rivers cut off the Russian
troops so of course that are on in the
Garrison side of the west side of the
river the ukrainians are Poise they've
knocked out most of the bridges the
Russians are resupplying with pontoons
and boats and what have you that can't
be sustained for long combat operations
so when if there's Russian forces
trapped I think that dam is going down
no matter what uh what's surprising to
me in the in my early days in the army
that the Soviets the Russians were far
better at disinformation and information
operations than they are today Putin has
two audiences the the International
audience and and of course as domestic
his domestic audience thinks he's
fantastic he's got the 80 some percent
you know positives despite the bad news
does he really though
how much can we trust of their media
according to a trifalgar
yeah I I do think he tends to be popular
I mean he's the Macho Man you know we
know how they have that image ingrained
in our brains you know in a t-shirt on
the back of it he has he has high
approval numbers because he turned
Russia from an international joke to to
a place that of course made sure that
people weren't drinking all the time one
of the biggest reasons why Putin is as
popular as he is is because he's not
drunk all the time like the previous
leader was
exactly and and then when you see you
see him reprimand people who do get
drunk who are in the factories who are
in in you know a major institutions of
power in in Russia he makes an example
out of them and even when there's
occasions to have a drink or have a shot
or have cheers he's like no I'm not
doing it so so that's you know one
reason why people see him as this kind
of you know savior to to Russia and
their interests and their country uh but
at the end of the day it's just another
politician and how long can he last with
losses and casualties stacking up in
Afghanistan you know eight years later
on eight years of war with Afghanistan
they finally withdrew in 1989 I mean but
this is this is Russia's strategy hasn't
it always been just send ridiculous
amounts of your troops and until you
just overwhelm your your opponents that
has been their approach since World War
actually since World War one yeah not in
Vietnam they were happy to fight The
Limited War by setting arms into Vietnam
I think after World War II they realize
it's just not a tenable way to fight
proxy wars using allies against the
United States and then that flipped in
the 80s when Reagan started using
proxies in Latin American elsewhere and
in Africa as well and and then in
Afghanistan where we you know we've
kindly realized we don't have to do all
the fighting here so you know the
policeman of the world remember that I
mean that notion from some years ago
limited War it was a Henry Kissinger
doctrine that they kind of instituted
Vladimir Putin is using you know this
this culture War rhetoric there's a lot
of people who feel that in the west
right now we've got these degenerate
deviant and just abhorrent ideologies
emerging from the left Vladimir Putin
seems to be capitalizing that outright
calling out this stuff as Satanism and
so there are a lot of people in the U.S
who think he's actually this it's this
great Christian Nation fighting back
against evil and degeneracy yeah he's
also speaking out against child
conversion therapy right and but is this
is this him realizing There's an
opportunity to propagandize or does he
actually believe the things he's saying
well I mean he has a problem on his
hands because I know he wants to
identify that as traditionally Russia
but Russia Today is is more is becoming
more and more increasingly Muslim than
it is Christian or european so you know
what is Russia Today I think that's it's
hard to get our minds around you know in
America but I think that's part of his
his land grab with you know south of
sashab Kazi and Georgia and now in
eastern Ukraine or ethnic Russians but
something really went wrong since 2014
Lion Air Putin is has managed to forge a
Ukrainian identity whether you're ethnic
Ukrainian or ethnic Russian they now
identify fully as Ukraine most of them
there's always exceptions I was uh I was
there when the my Dan protest started
and so I was
food was great uh I saw the burn the
building that they set on fire that I
was uh I got to see the statue that
they'd pulled down of Lenin yeah it was
a long complicated story and how that
all went down but I met a lot of these
people a lot of young people and they
all basically said the same thing we
remember what it was like under the
Soviet Union and we never want to go
back so there are a lot of people who
talk about the eastern region and it's
probably true for in the East a lot of
people who are ethically Russian they
speak Russian and view themselves as
more Russian but then you're going to
end up with a split in the country from
people who are like I remember the
Soviets you know we're not happy with
that and then they're gonna be a lot of
people who are just like I don't trust
the West I don't like their ideology you
remember and that's interesting because
you know their grandparents lived
through the hollow mode however you say
it the four the four starvation yeah
that's it in what 32-33 over the winter
and seven to ten million we don't even
know how many died ukrainians and it
happened in other countries
I mean it's a tough situation and the
Putin is stuck now he didn't have his
decisive knockout blow he did not get
zelinski he did not take Kiev and uh now
he's stuck in this fight I'm just
surprised I mean there are a lot of
people who firmly believe Putin is
winning I I think that's just not true I
know there's propaganda and it really
annoys me like you pull up American
social media in every single video is
like some Ukrainian Soldier flicking a
cigar being like Oh and I'm like come on
like I know they're not winning every
single fight you know but but you look
at where the the major news is breaking
where the major moves are happening
happening and what Putin's doing and
like yeah they're getting pushed out but
there's a lot of people who just I
suppose they don't want to believe it
they want to believe that you know
Russia is winning he's advancing Ukraine
is is is not winning my thought on this
is just did Putin not realize that NATO
was going to be it was going to be a
proxy war with NATO I mean you have
Russian pundits saying since the
beginning of this I think like in March
they're like we're at war with NATO okay
did he think he was gonna win that we
we're providing intelligence we're
providing weapons training not only that
our citizens volunteers and now we're
learning from The Intercept actual U.S
Special Operations on the ground in in
Ukraine why would Putin think he's going
to go up against NATO and win is it a
last stand or what is it yeah I think he
underestimated the resolve the
ukrainians which I did too as well I'm
surprised that they are able to beat
back the aerosol Airborne forces and
then you know overestimated his own
forces on paper good army pretty
modernized you know the front line
forces but look what happened I mean but
this also betrays a point here we have
to in Pennsylvania plays a role in this
I mean energy yeah so we're now in this
energy crisis here we're told gas prices
are growing up because of Putin that's
that's Biden's line uh but Pennsylvania
has the resources to become a leader in
energy in the world with our natural gas
we have one of the largest natural gas
deposits in around the globe we have
great high quality coal we have high
quality oil so my goal is as governor of
course is to make us number one in
energy production
there's a hundred billion dollars of
potential wealth out there to be
received by Pennsylvania if we can
produce that much you know it's all
about you know the capability my goal is
to have a pipeline
to Philly out to Delaware so we can
start exporting to Boston because Boston
had to bring in Russian ships in 2018 in
a cold winter remember the madness
because of the pipe there's no pipelines
from Pennsylvania so they brought in two
ships from Siberia 4 000 miles away so I
want to be able to support uh Boston but
maybe export also to Germany get them
off of Russian oil and gas and maybe our
friends in Poland and for sure the
lithuanians have already you know
committed that they wanted to buy it off
of Pennsylvania I was willing to
entertain a lot of this go green stuff
for a while but the moment you come out
and say you know Joe Biden says he wants
to get get us off fossil fuels he says
it was part of his campaign when he ran
for president then he shuts down
Keystone then he bans fracking in
certain areas and then he goes to Saudi
Arabia and begs for oil I'm like it's
not about getting it's not about
stopping fossil fuels I don't know what
the actual uh why actually let me just
ask you
how does this make sense that we got to
stop using fossil fuels and then he he
hurts the United States and then goes
over to Saudi Arabia and begs them to
keep up production so we can keep
getting fossil fuels what's what's the
reasoning then when we were entered
energy independent and gas was under two
bucks a gallon 184. 184 just just less
than what two years ago just over two
years ago and now we're begging the
Saudis and even go to the Venezuelans
and kind of winking and nodding to the
Iranians are you kidding me and and
exporting our wealth over these foreign
countries who aren't really that
friendly I mean we have a good relation
with the Saudis because of necessity
because who's around them and it's a
rough neighborhood but Pennsylvania
United States ought to be energy
independent and that's one thing you
know this is the age of Governors you
know I'm glad you've brought other
candidates on the show here Pennsylvania
can lead the way in making America
energy independent once again why you
think it is that they're advocating for
no energy Independence at home while
begging others for energy I mean do we
just not understand or or is it just I
wonder if it's that Democrat rats know
their base wants environmentalism but
they also know you can't have cheap gas
and environmentalism so they're just
lying
I think it's exactly that I think
they're driven by a gross ideology here
that that's making life harder more
expensive than the Working Class People
the Democrats claim they represent yeah
let me let me let me jump to this story
real quick but just really quick before
doing that you know they got to build
back better somehow what better way than
to destroy the previous version of it
and and I really wanted to ask you a
question doug because the Obama the
Biden Administration has specifically
stopped domestic energy exploration and
production will they stand in your way
as governor and can they stop you from
doing what you want to do in state
that's that's my Valley Way on state
lands I completely control that on
private lands with the cooperation of
Atlantis I don't know if we have time I
get a four-prong approach it's called
the Pennsylvania energy Independence act
it's not a gimmick it's actually I
developed this with the energy sector
and of course we want to do it
responsibly we want to do it cleanly we
want our trout being killed and
poisoning our land obviously we want
cancer causing agents and the energy
sector has proven they can do it you
know better the first part of course is
a rolling back uh our entry into this
Regional greenhouse gas initiative
Reggie which is a carbon tax it's
increased it's doubled almost our cost
of energy in Pennsylvania starting the
first of June so on day one we're going
to be out of it when I'm sworn in on 17
January and you'll see immediate relief
for the working class people out there
savings and energy so it's not a choice
between Heating and eating part two of
that of course is rolling back about
eight years of regulations from our
Department of Environmental Protection
within Pennsylvania that have gone too
far because it's it's so restrictive
that they're driving energy uh
businesses to Ohio West Virginia and
Texas and I want them back in
Pennsylvania and then of course I talked
about the pipeline one coming at across
from from Pittsburgh area to Philly and
I'll bring lots of great jobs I'll bring
uh security as far as energy goes it
will improve it for NATO and then also
I'd like to see a pipeline
towards Lake Erie and so uh and then of
course I'll open up State lands and do
doing that we I can do I can do all that
without being in uh stopped by the EPA
let me pull up this story it's from the
daily wire Bill Gates on energy crisis
it's good for the long run the reason I
think this is so important let me give
you a quick bit of context here they say
the billionaire Microsoft co-founder
explained during an interview with CNBC
that although Global economies cannot
immediately discard oil and gas current
shortages in the European energy Market
will prompt a faster transition away
from fossil fuels quote now without the
Russian natural gas being available in
Europe it's a setback we need to find
non-russian Hydra carbon sources to
substitute for those keeping those
economies in decent shape is a priority
now on the other hand it's good for the
long run because people won't want to be
dependent on Russian natural gas so
they'll move to these new approaches
more rapidly here's the point
for all the people that are very
concerned about climate change and the
environment and all that stuff hey man I
hear you but these people are lying to
you they're saying it's good that
Europe's in an energy crisis right now
Italy they're using Candlelight for
their stores the UK is preparing scripts
this is a guard the guardian reporting
the BBC's preparing these scripts for
when the blackouts hit now so now you've
got in the United States you've got gas
in California at eight bucks you've got
gas on the rise nationally it's over
four it was at four dollars something
right now they're telling you we have to
stop using this stuff because of climate
change and then Joe Biden goes to as you
mentioned Venezuela Saudi Arabia and
just says keep up their production they
clearly still want this stuff their
agenda is it's political and it does not
match what they're saying at home so I
used to be all about like okay you know
let's find renewable energies then I saw
them going overseas to our adversaries
so we're dependent on them okay Bill
Gates can point out we don't want to be
dependent on Russia you know what that
means it means American Energy
Independence it doesn't mean walking
away from and we have it and you know
I'm no fool I'm cognizant I'll be
challenged of course by the EPA and the
buying Administration when I'm governor
next year but we're going to do it
because that's that's underneath the the
Constitutional power of the states the
reason why I would say this is the age
of the governors we've seen we saw
during the covet shutdown which was
eye-opening for all of us whether
conservative or not we saw how dangerous
this trend was towards tyranny and
stripping away our freedoms that we just
took for granted we saw Pennsylvania
with very restrictive you know Powers by
Governor wolf and what never was a
governor more appropriately named and
then of course
and then of course Rhonda sanus in
Florida and I kind of say you know this
jokingly but I really do mean it I want
to bring a little bit of Florida to
Pennsylvania as far as freedoms go yeah
but but guys this is not what Bill Gates
wants and what Bill Gates wants is what
Bill Gates gets okay he paid how much
money to the corporate media 250 million
dollars he bought a lot of influence
here he helped spur on the inflation
reduction act which doesn't actually
reduce inflation but we have to
understand here when he's talking about
new approaches he's also talking about
specifically the businesses is that he
has invested in so he's not talking
about energy Independence because of the
United States Drilling and exploring
domestic energy he's talking about
unproven technologies that again have
not been tested most likely are
insufficient a lot of people are calling
them scams and rightfully so and and
when we see this larger problem in the
United Kingdom people will suffer
there's a big potential for a blackouts
people will lose their savings their
money because they're trying to just
afford the ability to heat their homes
and for Bill Gates this is a good thing
for the long run this is his approach
human suffering is good for the long run
if those are your tactics what's going
to be your end game and the end game is
going to be the same thing and the
carbon that he wants to reduce is of
course you Greta tunberg you know how to
tell you if she comes out she says we
got to get off carbon and all that stuff
and I'm sitting here and I'm like okay I
don't like the plastic in the oceans I
don't like the pollution you mentioned
we don't want our trout getting sick I'm
like yeah and I I want clean I want to I
want to go out to the Wilderness on a
hike and see no pollution and I'm like
when people throw garbage on the on the
ground and stuff like that and then I
see that she's not talking about China
or Indy at all yeah and they're such
massive polluters some of the largest
way way more than the US she doesn't
they don't mention that the U.S actually
reduce its carbon substantially more so
than these other countries they cut down
our energy they drive up our costs they
make it harder for the American working
class and then overseas they ignore what
everyone else is doing they don't ignore
it no no you don't understand it Bill
Gates advises the Chinese government
he's buddies buddies with the Chinese
government so he promotes them the
Chinese government he says on National
Television the Chinese zero covert
approach is the right approach they
should of course create the social
credit score he loves what China's doing
because at the end of the day it's not
about saving the environment that's just
the scam that they have on everyone else
to conjure up a larger power grab all a
part of the Great reset I'll throw you
one of the hardest Hardball questions
ever do you like what China is doing
heck no I'm watching my language this is
the family-friendly show heck no easy
question yeah I I I'm concerned not just
about the the lies in manipulation I'm
concerned about you know China seems to
be very much invested in US embracing
ideologies that are ripping this country
apart so while they're massively
expanding while their population is much
much larger than ours while they're you
know uh sinking Vietnamese fishing
vessels they're polluting like crazy
their their cities are so full of smog
there's there's one video of a screen
have you seen this one they have like
this big TV with a sunny day on it
because it's just brown skies yeah and
and look I don't want to see that here
but I don't think any of us are talking
about that no they're Reckless Reckless
and unforgiving they're buying garbage
from from Canada Canada is like we're
we're recycling they're buying it and
literally just dumping it in the ocean
they're not recycling any of it and it's
a scam all of it has been a larger scam
against against the the American people
the people of the world and again Bill
Gates's partnership with China tells you
everything you need to know about it but
it makes you feel good yeah I know right
yeah it's a big PR scam that's that's
the the the big problem man if you are a
moderate liberal or libertarian minded
person and you read the news and say hey
here's a thing they call you far right
in the media yeah if you like like the
big point that I keep trying to drive
drive home here is they keep saying we
got to reduce carbon whilst actively
trying to buy it overseas while ignoring
the carbon being produced by these other
countries because they're clearly lying
you point that out they say it's a
right-wing talking point yeah apparently
China is building a coal plant almost
every week now I mean is it a violation
of these treaties we have with them or
something it is because we're supposed
to sell them I guess a carbon tax or
whatever they're supposed to a certain
limit but for Pennsylvania we become
energy independent and start being a net
exporter and I call it Freedom gas I
mean that that's that's pretty clean
when it burns and it's going to lower
costs in our state which is so what it's
be cheaper to live here inflation will
go down you have better jobs and and
people want to live in Pennsylvania when
it's funny Bill Gates in his Ivory Tower
literally you know preaching it's a good
thing but he won't be affected he'll
still have his his private jet and his
private cars and his Mansions all with
his job giant carbon footprint you could
take away 90 of his wealth and he's
still a billionaire that's true he has a
lot of beachfront property for someone
who thinks the ocean levels are going to
be rising very soon and he probably has
a bunch of Apocalypse he he has he's the
biggest Farmland owner in the United
States he was asked directly hey how
come you don't Institute a lot of your
green policies on your Farms he's like
huh I don't know we don't have to and
I'm like he just got called out for his
hypocrisy and it's hypocrisy after
hypocrisy and Epstein's friend here is
not a good person and he doesn't have
your best interest at heart well so let
me ask you when you're talking a lot
about energy uh natural gas is that
specifically what you're able to person
are you talking everything I'm talking
about the three levels and Remy and I
have been out to a natural grass uh
natural gas grass grass is good too good
for the cats Freedom gas that's easier
for me to say uh rig out in Western PA
but so three levels natural gas is
massive in a marcelo's shell and uh we
have uh We've viewed how they extracted
it is safe the water tables aren't being
polluted they actually put a concrete
filter in to block our aquifers from
being contaminated from this proprietary
formula to use extracted and then of
course colon oil the oil is very high
grade I mean it's the kind of stuff that
you use in an important Machinery any
thoughts on this I think they said they
could if they had a way a plant in
Pennsylvania they could actually turn
that into gas for the cars as well yes
rebbies right and so I was talking with
one of the energy producers and he's
like all we need is refinery in
Pennsylvania and we can turn our natural
gas to automobile gas I'm like you've
got to be kidding me let's do that
gasoline gasoline natural gas into gas
with methane into gasoline I don't know
I didn't ask it for the details but I
just said let's do that have you have
you heard about uh I think Ian brought
this up was it you that they they turned
plastic into uh diesel yeah
um they found like a deoxygenated high
pressure high temperature environments
you can melt plastic back into oil it
needs to be refined into gasoline but
it's that's it's going to become a
valuable commodity it's recovering the
plastic yeah what do you think about
stuff like that are would you be
interested as governor in exploring ways
to other places we have this stuff
sitting around in the garbage heaps
stinking up I mean in the oceans let's
let's use it that way you can also
upcycle coal into graphene which is like
I don't know if you're familiar with
graphene is
everyone drink 21st century Building
Material it's like steel more conductive
than copper that's like a capacity every
capacitor like a battery
um it's a pure carbon what do you do you
like take two sheets of it and you twist
it or something like you do twistronic
graphene you can take multiple sheets of
it and they're putting it layering it on
top of each other one point uh there's
1.13 degrees uh eventually they're being
super conductive carbon it's this it's a
powder here yeah this is pure carbon for
sure and you can hit coal with lasers
and turn it into this stuff and then it
burns cleaner and then you can turn it
into building materials wiring and
what's going to happen by 2029 it'll be
globally
uh this will become the new it'll be
adopted essentially Peak graphing 2012.
so if we get on it now and we start
producing this stuff early let's let's
Ohio University's working on the
upscaling of coal pretty heavily into
graphene I would love Pennsylvania to
take the lead on something like that
check this out Ian Ian brought this up
uh so Ian's thing is graphene you know
when he's graph Ian uh but graphene is
oh he's writing it down Ian he got one
so but here's something really
interesting that Ian brought up
at the turn of the century in um the
1800s 1900s in New York they said that
there's going to be horse manure horse
manure piling 10 feet high the city will
be unlivable it'll smell then the car
got invented and there was no horse
manure at all it was gone but there was
a lot at the time Ian brings up a good
point that we're talking about global
warming with carbon in the atmosphere
but they have carbon capture technology
that can pull carbon and they can mine
it from the air to produce a a material
like graphene so when we're talking
about all this climate change stuff it
really does feel like people are
discounting human invention that we
might actually as Ian points out
have too little carbon in the atmosphere
at that point when we're not complaining
about it it's getting too cold we'll be
able to what you withdraw the carbon
dioxide from the atmosphere you can
deposit it on a metals and then turn it
into graphene the carbon you strip the
carbon out of the carbon dioxide you can
also take methane out of the atmosphere
turn it into carbon dioxide and then
turn it into graphene what's going to
happen is we're going to create an
industry where we're mining the air and
then we're going to start competing with
trees for carbon dioxide so we've got to
be real careful about The Way We Set
This Global industry in in sand burn
more gas wow got to burn more it's not a
bad idea if you can capture the carbon
right out of the Smoke Stack that I
think is ideal because you're not
introducing but at the same time we got
to start cleaning up what's already out
there too I love it especially since
we're the second largest producer of
Hardwoods uh in the in North America so
we got to balance that that's for sure
that's amazing what about sustainability
I mean can this this can't last forever
is there a timetable on how long you'll
so I I looked at a report and obviously
there's a lot of geological
interpretation here they're saying we
have about two or three centuries worth
of energy underneath our feet in
Pennsylvania wow yeah but whatever what
what about two or three centuries later
by then we're using Fusion Energy by
then we have graphene and we have we
have Mr Fusion on the back of our cars
like in Back to the Future Let's uh
let's let's talk about crime uh we got
the story from the Philadelphia Inquirer
yes Wawa's decision to close two stores
is a dire statement about Public Safety
in Philadelphia despite assertions at
the contrary the move by the locally
based convenience store chain speaks
volumes about the state of crime in the
city I'll just give you my personal
story in the state of crime in the city
we didn't live in Philly we live just
just across the bridge we're in we're in
South Jersey
five minutes away from the bridge when
the riots happened and what they call
the summer of love the 529 Insurrection
I thought we were fine I'm like well
we're not in Philly we got we got the
river there's people are gonna no I
heard the helicopters I heard the sirens
the the Riders crossed the bridge
all of a sudden now I'm sitting here
thinking
I'm not gonna sit around here and wait
for this kind of this level of violence
and this crime so he decided to leave we
came down to the the tri-state area here
West Virginia Harpers Ferry and since
then what we've seen out of Philadelphia
has been horrifying I mean as soon as we
got out we saw the story of the guy
holed up in his house shooting at cops
we're hearing uh just I mean you you had
the the wallow where everyone went in
and started ransacking everything now
Wawa is leaving we see this in Portland
too they just shut down I think the
Pearl District Starbucks because of
crime not that it was only a few months
ago they announced 16 other stores
nationwide be shutting down because
crime is skyrocketing so so what's going
on man why is why is crime through the
roof what can you do about it what can
we do about it it's funny crime comes up
a lot in the in the federal Senate races
but there's nothing a federal Senator
can do at the state level for crime and
exactly and so it's a bit disingenuous
and they talk about you know they're
going to bring you know Law and Order
back it's like dude constitutionally how
do you do that exactly but a governor
has a lot to say about it the irony is
of course my opponent is the attorney
general he's been in that job for six
years and he's got one job enforcing Law
and Order and he's failed on his watch
you know John Adams said facts are
stubborn things and so let me just give
you some facts I don't do I'm not a
politician I don't do sound bites like
that but the fact is crime has gone up
nearly 40 on his watch
Statewide Statewide wow where the fourth
highest in fentanyl death so Robbie and
I were there in Kensington a couple
weeks ago I'll have red describe what
our experience there
um homicides we're looking at on track
for about 600 this year it's about 430
as of today a thousand carjackings 4 400
robberies a couple thousand shootings uh
the gravediggers in Philadelphia said
they can't keep up burying the dead
teenagers and uh you know my my opponent
can't run on this record and sadly thank
God for you know that we have alternate
Outlets like you guys because the
traditional media covers for them
because if that was a republican they'd
be breathless reporting on how you know
this this person had failed the people
of the state you know and turned his
backs on instead of doing his job and
trying to protect the people we saw the
you know the Mayhem in the in the
Mayfair District that's crazy we saw the
shooting after football game in Roxboro
another safe area of Philly we saw a
carjacking outside in Chester County
outside of Philly of a mom and a
daughter going to school and being you
know the carjacked at you know seven
o'clock in the morning oh yeah yeah I
saw that yeah I mean it's heartbreaking
real people are suffering and so what
can I do about it and uh number one
we're going to become a law and order
State because Shapiro is part of the
defund the police group he's friends
with BLM and antifa so they'll they'll
know that their governor has their back
and then secondly be working with the
general assembly to make sure they're
fully funded we'll expand a number of
police we have on the on the ground
we'll need we need more the people in
Kensington in Philadelphia are asking
for more presents and then finally
I'll be surging special prosecutors in
the Philly with the authorization of the
House and Senate because there are
Constitutional Powers Josh Shapiro was
given that authorization and he refused
to use it and instead of putting
criminals in jail he's worked with the
wolf Administration to release release
about 10 000. I know fetterman's getting
hit on the head a lot about how he's
released you know voted to release in
the parole board you know all these
murders what have you Josh Shapiro was
also on that board yeah look it's one
thing uh there was a tweet I saw it was
Tim Ryan saying he wants to reduce the
prison population in Ohio immediately
this is knee-jerk reaction from a lot of
people on the right saying like wow
that's a devastating in bed but the
first thing he says is he wants to get
marijuana off the schedule and that's
that's a there's a there's a big
difference between people who are in
jail for non-violent drug offenses and
people who are convicted of murder the
thing about fetterman is that many of
the people he's actually talked about
getting out are people who are convicted
of murder granted he says oh it was a
wrong conviction or it was you know
wrong for this reason or that reason or
their protests okay well that is you
talking about people who are convicted
of murder and I and I fully respect if
someone's in you know prison and they're
innocent and you can prove it they
should be really it should never happen
like that but it's not the same as you
know for fetterman if you if he wants to
come out and say non-violent dragon
offenses should not be handled this way
then I'm like okay all right right on
key distinction right the problem is you
look at New York and there's other
places and they're letting out violent
offenders there was a there was a story
about a guy who had like committed like
40 robberies laughing saying you keep
letting me out and I keep doing it
that's that's the problem you agree yeah
there's an important distinction to make
here because personally I'm for Criminal
Justice Reform especially when it comes
to victimless crimes but at the same
time what what they're doing is
absolutely absurd it's absolutely crazy
it's almost as if they really
deliberately want to make the situation
as unbearable and as bad as possible on
the streets and you see a huge rise in
crime specifically where George Soros
has invest invested into the attorney
generals into the district attorneys and
uh correct me if I'm wrong but but it
looks like Shapiro got two donations uh
for his campaigns twice from George
Soros and has been supported by him that
is a fact and so we are in Kensington
it's that that's the only open-air drug
Market in America
a lot more in San Francisco and New York
City in L.A that's the biggest one in
America yeah and it was heartbreaking
because honestly that for the people
that are trying to live there and just
be safe and raise a family there is no
safe place you know even in their homes
their shootings and the bullets go in
and the kids um one grandmother raising
five kids by herself said they know the
difference between a firecracker and a
gunshot you know and they know what to
do they know to run upstairs and lay
flat on the floor and I think the
youngest one's like five years old the
other thing is the school's just locked
down because of some sort of crime and
the parents aren't told why the school's
locked down so now your kids you know
are locked in and not able to come home
but you don't know if it's an internal
or an extra you don't know what the
problem is and so there's just a lot of
fear that it's instilling into the
parents because they don't know every
day if their kids are gonna what happens
when a school gets locked down like how
long is a lockdown for I think various
times from what she was telling us we we
talked to different people when we were
down there but her story was is it just
keeps happening it's something that's
almost weekly and it varies you know it
might just be you know for an hour
because they heard there was something
in the vicinity and so they were trying
to keep the kids in before they let them
out you know to to head home but you
know sometimes it's internal and if
that's the case I don't know how long
that might be might be for hours what I
don't get is that when this kind of
stuff happens the only thing I hear from
your modern liberal or leftists is it's
the guns that's the problem and I'm like
well it's crime it's criminals you know
uh Pennsylvania is pretty good on gun
laws I'm told is that is that is that
true
yeah I mean it's I haven't lived there
most of the state obviously is is
strongly advocating for Second Amendment
um you know there's one of the most
restrictive cities uh you know in a
nation is Philadelphia it hasn't done
them very good but it's my understanding
is it's still not nearly as restrictive
restrictive as all of New Jersey because
you know I'm living in the Jersey side
and there that's absolutely true they're
giving you warnings but I bring this up
because this means that you know I heard
a story about people in Philadelphia and
they're armed and everything's fine they
go to Jersey and also they're getting
arrested and I'm like wait regular
law-abiding citizens are armed in
Philadelphia well yeah if you're pulled
over you got a Pennsylvania plate don't
answer any questions in Jersey if you
have a weapon on you but but I mean uh I
play the fifth the issue clearly is not
the guns or the gun owners right the
area is the issue is clearly the
criminals and you know it's one of the
reasons I didn't want to be in New
Jersey because of how insane the laws
were I was told that if someone look I'm
fi I was five minutes from the bridge we
would drive five minutes and you could
see Philadelphia you look out the window
and you can see the buildings and
everything and I was told in Jersey that
if someone broke into my house I had a
duty to retreat from my own home in
Jersey and I'm like what is nuts where
do you Retreat too thank you I'm like do
I jump out the window and run Barefoot
my boxers down the street yes because
they were like is is that better than
killing someone and I'm like dude if
someone's threatening my life I could be
out in the winter and my bear that's the
nuts so I'm I look at you know
Philadelphia and I'm told the laws are
better so we do have the castle doctrine
in Pennsylvania of course what you know
you can only open fire and engage you
know a villain a potential of the
perpetrator when they're in your house
that's when the laws are pleading in
your hands just really quickly if you oh
sorry go ahead on the porch is that in
the house you got to make sure it's far
enough in that if the gunshot throws
them back they're not out right so with
their hands if they're if their hands on
the door the doors cracked open that's
not enough
all the way in where where was that uh
story where the the Angry ex-boyfriend
do you see this one tried banging on the
door and tried breaking the door open
and the dad shot through the door oh yes
that that wasn't Pennsylvania was it I
think it was I don't think so I I don't
remember that story specifically but but
if you're a governor how would you
approach the Second Amendment what
action would you take on it well
obviously will be become a section a
second amendment Sanctuary State and
I'll be signing into law some of the
bills I actually have in thank you I
like that yeah and so I'll be signing
into law I don't know if I'll go as far
as nukes but clearly not
specific would you be okay for
constitutional carry yeah absolutely and
actually I'm a co-sponsor of that bill
in the Senate great awesome we're
constitutional care in West Virginia
it's fantastic it needs to be that way
and I don't even get why we have a
Second Amendment right and I have to pay
25 bucks to get a license every couple
years it's like are you kidding me
additionally I have a bill and I'm a
prime sponsor of an ascendant I hope the
sign of the law when I'm Governor I will
actually where it will prohibit law
enforcement within Pennsylvania from
cooperating with the federals if Joe
Biden comes in to enforce to enforce
unconstitutional laws nice man yeah so
the nuclear weapons thing is uh it's
more of a cultural Point using something
that's that's relatively shocking first
uh yeah private companies private
entities can have nukes I mean you've
got major uh weapons manufacturers that
fill out the forms I forgot what it's
called we talked to a guy who had an FFL
and he explained as a form for nuclear
weapons and uh when the second amendment
was written you could have a a frigate
you could have a man of war you could
have a private warship and you could
actually contract with the government
that's what we have today with these
with private military contractors and
weapons manufacturers so I think if
people are concerned about a private
citizen getting access to biological and
nuclear weapons instead of just deciding
one day that the Constitution doesn't
matter we should actually say okay well
let's amend the Constitution as we were
supposed to do it's more of a point that
over a long enough period of time people
seem okay with the fact that the
constitution has been eroded
that that that's the whole point of I
think that's probably the most important
thing that I've heard today is that
we're seeing infringements on our rights
through uh you know a thousand little
Cuts here and there and instead of doing
the right thing and saying okay do you
have a second Amendment right or not and
approaching it from a constitutional
amendment process it's being
circumvented by by laws and by
bureaucrats and bureaucracy and what
have you additionally another piece of
legislation they'll be signing law of
course is reciprocity recognizing
people's right from other states coming
through that's amazing I'm glad to hear
it I love the Constitutional carry stuff
it's too easy it's very clear to me I
mean so we know what the US Constitution
says you know should not be infringed in
Pennsylvania Constitution says uh that's
your right to keep and bear arms shall
not be questioned wow really yes that's
beautiful yeah law abiding citizens
shouldn't be treated like criminals it's
a simple it's a simple idea but so so
constitutional carry but let's let's get
a little into the nitty-gritty I guess
what about limitations on you know
magazine size or you know if you're
saying it's a sanctuary State I mean how
does that apply to say the NF fa like
selective fire rifles fully automatic
weapons yeah I mean I honestly I haven't
gone that far but I am troubled by the
by the limitations because we even seen
Joe Biden talk about handguns you know
and having more than six rounds that
would be a revolver he doesn't even know
what he's talking about yeah seriously
there's a that it's that it's illegal
that you could be arrested in New Jersey
because you have a 30 round magazine are
you kidding me I mean really I mean most
most veterans have some of those left
over from the M16 days I mean true and
not just that there was a viral video
where it was in Italy I think something
you're only allowed to have three rounds
and this individualist woman I think the
one I think it was a woman got attacked
by a boar and then fired three times and
the board did not stop oh crap and so
people like this is why but you look at
what happened someone tweeted you know
what am I supposed to do in 30 to 50
feral Hogs come into my you know my yard
and then all of the liberal anti-gun
people are laughing as if it's not a
real problem and it is they don't
understand you know people getting
helicopters and fly around having to
call the boar population because they're
dangerous and they destroy the
environment but these people don't
understand that they live in New York
where there is no boar problem and then
vote for you to be hobbled when you do
have a boar problem you know it's it's
nice when you're living in a you know in
a little bubble somewhere you know and
you know safe and cozy and you have good
Wi-Fi and you know good transportation
and you have a private jet and the rest
of us so if it's kind of you mentioned a
boar and we lived in Germany for 10
years and so I was out with our son and
a couple of his friends when they're
little kids and it's an Old Quarry in
Germany and all of a sudden it's this
this boar came jumping off of the top of
the Quarry and bounded off the walls and
came straight for us and all the kids
were running and I'm like what do you do
and so I stepped on a rock and stared at
it and it lifted it now looked me in the
eyes and then veered away it worked they
said stare the animal down and he veered
right in front of me and did you make
your shoulders big or anything
I I'm just naturally yeah how tall are
you are you yeah so that was standing on
a rock because I hopped on a rock so he
didn't increased my height and he did
Veer away do you think there's value to
having different gun laws in cities and
in rural areas or do you just kind of
keep it I don't I do believe that the
second amendment should be consistent
across whether you're you know City or
rural
um you know the lawlessness lawlessness
in Philly I mean if that mom had a had a
sidearm with her and a carjacker came
and she could have put him out of his
misery instead of being terrorized and
what have you I honestly think there
wouldn't be a carjacking because people
would be like I better not even try
because then This Woman's probably I
remember in the 70s I had an aunt that
lived in Florida and we go visit her
down in Vero Beach and we were told
don't beep at people back then because
they might just shoot you so yeah an
armed Society is a polite Society
you respect other people you don't freak
out you don't you don't you don't curse
at people you don't try to attack people
you don't try to steal their stuff or
violate their rights and as long as you
do that you'll be fine but but again we
also have to understand the criminals
we'll always find guns they will always
have you know things like machine guns
they will always have 30 round magazines
and if the general public is limited to
like let's say five rounds right a
criminal knows that that when he's
robbing the store oh the clerk only has
five rounds so if I'm in a shootout with
him one shot two shot three shot four
shot five shot he has to reload my turn
to get him now and it puts the average
citizen at a disadvantage when criminals
who don't follow the law anyway will
violate it and of course will use it in
order to justify the punishment against
the average law-abiding human being I
I'm not even I'm just tired of even
hearing it and saying it because it is
it is basic arithmetic it is it is so
rudimentary it is one plus one equals
two if citizens can't have guns and
criminals are already breaking the law
you're basically just saying the people
who don't care for the law can carry
weapons it's just one plus one equals
two and everybody listen to the show
knows it everybody at this table knows
it and we keep saying it but it doesn't
resonate with these people who are
trying to ban guns that the people only
only law-abiding people are going to pay
attention to those laws I just how do
you solve this in the bottom line do we
have a second amendment right or not and
if we don't then then do a
constitutional convention and not come
here and slowly strip away these rights
here and there because you're right when
you when you take the weapons away from
the from the innocent from the citizens
of course then only the criminals will
be harmed and we've seen that over and
over again you look at Chicago I mean
I'm from Chicago the Wild Wild West man
and this is why I always tell my friends
who aren't from the city why you don't
get involved in Road road rage incidents
why like I'll be driving with a friend
and someone will cut them off and start
wailing on the horn and flipping them
off and I'll be like you want to die
because you never know if who you're
flipping off is going to be some gang
banger who's who's you know looking for
trouble it's a city where the criminals
the people who are intent on committing
crimes or who outright just don't care
about the law are the ones who are armed
you never know so it's funny an armed
Society is a polite Society well in that
respect in Chicago don't pick fights
unless you know for sure like don't pick
fights you know outright and then don't
get into a fight even if it's unless you
you know your circumstances so I've been
what I mean by that is if someone is
getting up in your face and they're
threatening you the fight the the fight
you've always won is the fight you've
avoided is the saying Chicago is a place
where I've seen people get into fights
that it's just like you want to talk
smack about me you know put up your
dukes and I got this okay and pulls out
a gun and that and they're going to be
criminals and the other issue is if they
have a gun these people are more likely
to to hurt you with it as opposed to
your law-abiding citizen who does not
want that fight so that's why I've you
know especially growing up in Chicago
I've just been like
we we'd be better off if the people were
scared to come near me to commit a crime
because I'd be armed because I'm telling
you all the criminals are armed as it is
they make videos of themselves waving
the guns around and all we can do is
cower and cross our fingers and hope
they're not going to shoot us
that's how crazy it gets for the most
part you don't got to worry about
getting shot in Chicago a lot of people
seem to think that because it's really
bad you're like walking down the street
motor flying everywhere I'll tell you
how bad it is it's um south side of
Chicago going to bed and hearing
gunshots it's getting a call from your
friend and saying I'm seeing some guy
drag a body down the alley those things
those things actually happened in my
life it's getting off of 290 on
Independence and then someone driving
past just pointing a Gun and shooting at
my car for no reason that's what
Chicago's like but those are a handful
of incidents in the 20 plus years when I
before I finally moved out so you know
some people have this idea that you go
to Chicago and then every day you're
going to be getting shot at no but
should you ever you're not going to be
happy about it right so something's got
to change let's jump to this next story
let's get uh let's get National with it
from timcast.com evidence implicating
Hunter Biden in 459 crimes was just sent
to every member of Congress the report
was produced following a 13-month and
investigation into material found on his
laptop
the file was sent to All 535 members of
Congress October 20th and includes 140
alleged business related crimes 191
sex-related offenses and 128
drug-related crimes according to the sun
it was also sent to District Attorneys
and U.S attorneys for the jurisdiction
in which the alleged crimes occurred
okay here's my question is anything
going to happen
I want to let's break down the crimes
you gotta let's go through all the
crimes give me some of the hot ones the
hot ones there's a lot of photos and
videos that you could see
how about you watch them how about you
watch them tonight maybe I'll do that in
my room alone how's that no I'm just I
think he's been just living the criminal
lifestyle and not all crime is I think
not all crime is evil like if there's an
evil law you have a Justice you have a a
duty to violate that illegal that
horrific law like in Nazi Germany for
instance but um you know I think he's
just been dodging it because his dad's
the VP and now the president and and
maybe he's got what's coming to him like
if he's been hurting people especially
do you've been hurting himself I don't
know I I think the reason Hunter has
gotten away with so much is because at
the highest level the doj is effectively
politicized so uh you look at stories
like this and you wonder why why is this
guy not not getting arrested but uh
let's let's break it down to actually a
more a personal level let's just say
fine you don't talk about the Biden
family let's talk about the pregnancy
centers that were firebombed you saw
that story yes were any of those in in
Pennsylvania I don't believe so because
I know one right over here like not that
far away we actually had one of our
reporters go drive out to it uh these
people nothing
I'm not I'm not hearing anything and
that's a terrorist attack it's terrorism
and nothing but what do we hear about
these pro-lifers so uh we you talked
about Mark Houck and how you know one
Saturday three weeks ago four weeks ago
about 30 agents showed up with 15 cars
and uh on an early morning we call that
a night raid in Afghanistan we'd help
plan these Ops where we could take down
tough armed terrorists that have killed
people and then sent in special
operators about 30 or so usually you
know earlier in the morning than seven
but uh that we we do that not
proportionally towards a pro-lifer
because he got in a shouting match with
with an opponent of his position and
apparently the guy was cussing over his
kid and so Mark pushed him in a lower
court threw the case out and now the
feds are to come in with overwhelming
Force that's obviously political I had
never dreamed in my lifetime we'd see
the Department of Justice and
potentially the FBI being politicized so
much because we have firebombing of
crisis pregnancy centers but then
nothing happens in defending their
rights but of course it's heavy-handed
abuse and we saw two priests arrested up
in New York state now as well for being
pro-life wow and praying outside a
clinic praying praying I mean it should
not be surprising my opponent Josh
Shapiro instead of fighting for our
rights during the shutdown he sued the
Little Sisters of the Poor I mean he
sued nuns who sued nuns over a religious
issue twice twice it seems like an overt
violation of the First Amendment look if
they're gonna make an argument about
like an assault or something it's like
sure but a federal case out of it I mean
that's the meme don't make a federal
case out of it that's true it was a
local protest we used to have back in
the day I mean maybe this is just a
Trope and maybe there's a reason to
complain about it but people get into
bar fights and and the cops would be
like go home guys you're wasting
everybody's time with this these days
it's you make a federal case out of it
yep and they are and that's very
chilling dude so you know what's
interesting Tim is that the Democrats
said blacklisted 21 Republicans uh a
year and a half ago two years ago and I
was number one in their hit list for
some reason they thought I was going to
derail their plans in Pennsylvania which
we will and uh they colluded with the
media this came out in the salon article
this is not conspiracy it's a fact they
admitted the DNC and dlcc Democrat
legislative Campaign Committee they
worked with the media to try to take me
down uh and it didn't work it made me
more popular actually but I think most
people though seeing Ed Harmon and
attacks and people attacking your
character and your work and your your
books your dissertation your your
service that it mostly would drive
people just to sit down and shut up and
that's the problem they had with me
that's why the media is so frustrated
and aggravated because I won't shut up
because I mean rebby and I 30 years in
the Army moving around the world to 12
years out of the country 10 uh 12 moves
um I had a sweet job lined up I was
going to ride off in the sunset in a
comfortable retirement and I could not
do that because your generation was
getting the country for me worse off
than how I got it for my dad and that's
my motivation and they're not they're
used to politicians being a bunch of
cowards and I ain't going anywhere we're
going to win on November 8th we're going
to turn the corner on this how can I ask
you how old you are 58 58 y'all were
supposed to give us flying cars we were
yeah Jordan Here Comes George Jetson we
got one we got we got a recession in
2008 now we got economic crises but now
I can appreciate you standing up and I I
could not walk away from it and I could
have I had the sweet job making a lot
more than a senator makes but it's not
about the money I fought for these
freedoms I defended these freedoms I
love my country you know I love it so
much that I was willing to lay down my
life for it no hero but uh it was
heartbreaking to me I struggled with
that and Robbie can tell you I was
having trouble leaving the Army I was I
got too old I reached Colonel that's as
high as I can get in my career field
there's no Generals in the field that I
work and uh I was what I just said I
said to a young man and uh at a radio
station he looked over at me and I'm in
uniform about to retire and he said well
Colonel why don't you do something about
it and I was like
ouch that hurt uh I'm hearing that uh uh
your opponent's not gonna debate you he
refuses to see me on the stage why why
he's a freaking coward he's got nothing
to run on so he's hiding I mean here you
are sitting down with us you have no
idea what we're going to talk about what
stories we're going to pull up it's it's
been an hour we've had Carrie Lake on
we've had we've had a bunch of
Republicans I'll give a shout out to Jen
Pearlman a democrat in Florida who also
came on and you know it was it was great
like we disagreed a lot of things and
it's just so difficult to get
Democrats and leftist activists there's
like two that that we've had on the show
more than once uh shout out to vosh for
everybody who doesn't like them hey man
he's willing to come here and argue with
us
but they won't even debate they won't
they won't debate you I think Katie
Hobbs the same thing she's not debating
not debating in Arizona not debating in
Wisconsin not debating in Maryland right
here Dan Cox he's a good friend he's
going to be a great Governor here and
his opponent's not debating him wow you
know what I think it is honestly the
truth would hurt their campaigns yep I
agree of course that's it they they need
to keep people in a in a tight space
where there is a controlled narrative
and I'm gonna I'm gonna you know I'm
sorry beat the dead horse but
they will come out and claim we've got
to reduce carbon emissions while Joe
Biden's dumping the Strategic petroleum
Reserve which is is keeping petroleum
flowing and then go and bag you know our
Rivals for oil they clearly want the oil
they're just lying to you about it I
think you say something like that in
debate and they go hey wait a minute
that's why they don't want to have a
debate absolutely first thing you bring
up among a bunch of other things I mean
you can talk about the riots they want
to talk about January 6. you say okay
well 529 there were a bunch of riots
they fire bombed a guard post at the
White House these are the things that
the media doesn't want to talk about and
if the media is not advancing The
Narrative then well I'll put it this way
they don't need to enter or enter a
situation where their constituents will
hear anything outside of their
controlled narrative that's exactly it
how do you break through to regular
people then confront them
meet them on the street be like that's
what I did uh but but hey I mean what
other way then go face to face be like
hey you won't debate me let's have a
conversation right here right now let
the American people decide and I think
we need more conversations and and the
fact that we don't have conversations
we're losing our civility because of
that because when you're able to look
someone eye to eye this is the reason
why we do the show in person here
there's there's an energy there's
there's there's no uh bullcrap there's
there's no nonsense you say something I
disagree with I'm gonna call you out on
it
um but but I still respect a human being
if they come from a different
perspective and experience but when
you're not able to face somebody you're
able to vilify them a lot easier and I
and I think we're reaching a point in
this country where it's becoming very
very dangerous to how partisan everyone
is it is chilling you know so how do I
get the message out and so Facebook of
course clamped down on me back on
October 17th 2020. I I had the greatest
reach on that platform for somebody in
politics I'm not a politician
but despite that and and so because it I
can't boost posts but despite that I'm
the number one in the nation over
Democrat and everyone else on reach and
Facebook because we told people how we
circumvent it you share you share to
your pages manually share and so that so
social media is one way Robbie and I
have traveled the entire state every
single County several times meeting
people eyeball the eyeball we probably
the past couple years we probably took a
hundred thousand hands I don't even know
and taking time we've been doing it for
two years because of all that's been
going on with covid and just people were
hopeless in Pennsylvania and so we get
invited to all these different counties
and events and things and so we went you
guys would have a great YouTube show the
three of you guys co-hosting it talking
about policy and stuff I love it you
know rippy's our secret weapon on the
campaign here I mean it's fantastic I'm
the introvert that is sacrificing and
using a microphone when I would rather
not the uh the guy down in Mexico does
this he does his daily speeches or
whatever where like what's his name
obrador I'm not super familiar but he
like or maybe maybe I don't know if he's
still there but I remember you know
being told he like comes out of the
balcony every day and talks about what's
going on and just like lays it out he's
very blunt very personable this is the
future of you know people want this they
want authenticity they want real
conversations they don't want sound
bites they don't want talking points
they just want to be like give it to me
straight I think one of the challenges
is that the new then there's there's the
left and the right but it's like a new
kind of left and right right I you know
I I grew up in Chicago very liberal now
they call me conservative and stuff
whatever but I think the difference is
you can tell me painful truths I'll hear
it and maybe I'll be like well it's a
good point man I don't know how you
solved that problem we have we have
conversations about pro-life pro-choice
and you know uh Sheamus a good friend of
ours who's a Catholic conservative very
pro-life we would have arguments and
then and then we'd laugh and tell jokes
to each other because we can get along
we can live together we're willing to
hear things we don't like or don't agree
with we're willing to argue
The Divide now is between people who
just don't want to hear it at all
there's something about politics where a
lot of it's like managing morale I think
as a politician or as a leader or
something and like if things are bad and
you come out and tell everyone hey
things are bad they might panic and then
that makes things worse so you want to
be like no everything's fine but then
that can be a lie and you're like I
don't want a lot of people but so what
do you do you just keep like a like a
positive mindset about the problems and
like um this is the solution yeah I'm
glad you brought that up yeah well I was
just going to say we we try to point
people to the fact that it doesn't have
to be this way and we try to encourage
them each one of you can do something
and if we all come together and we all
we're all gonna like you're just saying
you know we're all gonna have different
backgrounds different opinions but if we
can all agree to come together on some
issues we can make a difference and that
was that was one of the big ways of
encouraging people and to watch out for
each other right like to remember you
know
um you know
be your Neighbor's Keeper kind of thing
you know if somebody's struggling you
know help them out you know and a lot of
people came together and met during
um the pandemic they tell them about
that Fireside yeah at our rally so
we started uh Fireside Doug started
fireside chat because people were so
confused with our shutdown in
Pennsylvania because it was so Random
how how it was happening and businesses
couldn't figure out like can I stay open
or or am I on Melissa has to close and
what's that look like and so anyway Doug
got on every night for about a half hour
and just kind of laid out the latest
here here's the list and he sometimes
was just reading through all the the
rules and talking to people and people
were asking questions hey I have a hair
salon so seriously I can't be open you
know but the abortion clinics are open
but I can't cut hair I mean you know it
was it was like people just wanted to
know like well what's going on why is
that going on and then Doug was able to
get his staff work to hit his staff did
not turn anyone down they even got calls
at 2 A.M they did not turn anyone away
from the entire State they didn't just
take care of the 33rd District they were
taking calls wait wait and one of them
was actually talking to a lady in
Philadelphia during the time you were
talking about with all the burning and
everything she lived above a store and
she could hear him crashing and breaking
everything and nobody was answering and
she called his number got some of his
staff and she said the police won't come
what do I do and so the staff stayed on
the phone with her until it quieted down
because she was a she was fearful for
her life
and they they they're lying about what
happened with those riots it's just it's
the craziest thing to me and uh again
it's probably why they don't want to
debate why we're saying it across the
board because you you talk about the
property damage the billions of dollars
that I've seen these uh um these these
talking points where they'll say oh
there's only a few neighborhoods some
viral tweet among a Democrat personality
said oh the right ones to claim that the
country was burning during major riots
but it was only a few neighborhoods it
was actually really small towns it was
it was widespread rampant and everywhere
for whatever reason you wanna you wanna
say it was because people were angry
about George Floyd or you want to say
they were angry because they were locked
up because of covet regardless Michael
Tracy journalist he went to these small
towns all over the country that people
didn't know about and he saw the same
thing boarded up Windows spray paint
please don't hurt us we support you
please leave us alone it's nightmarish
and there's there's never really been
any kind of reconciliation or apology or
admission in fact the bite
Administration
Joe Biden staffers were donating to bail
these people out that's right Kamala
Harris was fundraising to bail these
people out it's just this simple
crime freaks me out I don't want to have
to worry about it look for me
we we were swatted here I think we got
like 13 swattings you know are you
familiar with swellings for sure so we
have to deal with that you know doing a
high profile show of course we're gonna
have security concerns so naturally with
crime going up it matters a lot to me if
I'm going to go to a place and it's
already that we have security concerns I
don't I don't want to think about that
but it's really simple on some of the
biggest issues the economy the cost of
goods and crime you've got Democrats who
have actually supported and bailed out
rioters and criminals advocated for
letting out convicted murderers and then
on on gas prices Joe Biden actually
campaigned on getting us off fossil
fuels so I I just tell people look
there's a lot of things you can complain
about culturally there's a lot of
cultural issues you want to talk about
uh pro-life versus pro-choice I hear you
but right now I know it's what's hurting
you the most and it's your gas prices
are making it harder hard enough you
can't even get to work if you can't get
to work how are you going to have a job
then because of the cost of gas going up
you can't now buy good
they're saying I saw a report I think it
was CNBC we've got 25 days left in the
in the U.S diesel supply for I think
it's distillate Supply now that doesn't
mean we're going to run out it just
means it's the lowest it's been since
2008. these things don't have to be this
way that's right I I understand a lot of
people may be concerned about you know
other issues in the culture War but you
can't complain about crime and gas and
then vote for Democrats it's not just
the culture War I would say it's more of
a psychological War a former KGB
Defector Yuri besmanov uh when talking
about psychological warfare subversion
and control of Western Society said
specifically quote exposure to True
information does not matter anymore a
person who is demoralized is unable to
assess true information the facts tell
nothing to him even if I shower him with
authentic proof document and pictures
and I I think that quote definitely
Rings true today with our modern society
especially with the mass amounts of kind
of hypnosis mind control that that is
really out there which some people have
described as fifth generational Warfare
now how do we overcome that I think it's
it's it's a lot harder uh than just just
said well let's uh give people something
to live for let me ask you about what's
going on in these schools
so we saw this in Virginia there uh
Ian's actually got one of these books
these are these are books that are rated
this one right here genderqueers gender
queer I don't know if you guys have seen
we've had that in my testimony uh two
days ago in the senate in Harrisburg 18
and up on Amazon
but these books are in grade school
libraries and when parents simply say
hey this material is not appropriate for
my kid they get kicked out of these
meetings they get told not to speak they
get they get the boot and then we're
told just that this is the kind of stuff
that grade school kids should have
access to so so was there something that
happened recently with you guys or you
know just tell me what your thoughts are
yeah we had a hearing in Harrisburg and
brought in uh several testifiers several
moms from the Southeastern part of the
state and uh one of the moms had a stack
about 10 different books and she read
from one of them which was completely
disgusting it's it's it's it's it's it
repugnant it's that bad do you remember
which book specifically this one was
I don't she read it it was so bad that
the committee chair said okay we
understand now
um but the pictures in some of those
books that she had there are extremely
graphic and it's for elementary ed kids
um and if you and I share that materials
with with uh underage people that that
would be an offense we'd be arrested
that's right that disgusting Josh
Shapiro my opponent supports that being
in the libraries we actually had a bill
that would protect kids from obscene
material in the schools age-appropriate
books and it was called book Banning by
the Democrats and our Democrat Governor
wolf vetoed it and my opponent cheered
on the same side here they celebrate of
course gender pronoun games in our
schools our schools are becoming really
a culture War class in Pennsylvania
because they know if they can
indoctrinate the kids they get votes in
you know in 18 years kids are told not
to tell their parents if they're
transitioning or which pronouns they're
using and the parents will get on board
later on Levine is part of this the
great Dr Levine our secretary of Health
in Pennsylvania now the second most
powerful Health official in the nation
here and Admiral now a woman of the year
you can't make this stuff up many people
talk about defending women's rights but
they can't even Define what a woman is
now I mean it's insane yeah Matt Walsh
is doing I think he's doing a screening
tour I know he's got a big rally in
Tennessee
um but you've seen Matt Walsh's
documentary what is a woman yep I mean
that's that's it right there look I'm
I'm all for uh making sure people are
living happy happy and healthy lives for
for the trans Community but we're
talking about now is it's a simple issue
parents saying hey me personally I don't
think it is right for my children to
read a book that shows graphic sexual
depictions and they're being called book
burners fascists transphobes domestic
terrorists if you talk too loud in the
school board meeting something's really
weird about that yeah there is I I you
know what I would just say you can ask
well if you ever get the chance because
he's not gonna debate you you just ask
him do you think Talent like you think
uh Banning Playboy would be book
Bannings is that a Banning Banning a
book to ban Hustler from schools we're
not talking about telling kids they
can't read ideas it's specifically that
these are adult adult oriented things
you know it's one thing if you're like
and actually actually I brought this up
with uh I can't remember who I brought
it up with um
we have a lot of guests the Bible has
certain depictions in it that are
actually adult and graphic and my
attitude is yeah the parents should be
there talking with their kids and
deciding if they want their kids to be
reading certain things I don't care
where it is I don't care if it's a
religious text or if it's a book the
idea that teachers will decide for the
parents and the parents have no say
somehow equates to book Bannings is is
ludicrous yeah and we we see the videos
on lives of tick tock you know and
they're using their platform to
indoctrine me and and that's that's
that's an abuse of power there you're
there to educate not to indoctrinate we
want to teach kids you know how to think
not what to think and that's that's a
dangerous Trend here and now that
there's a push to to force the parents
out of their their kids lives in their
education in their choices and what have
you in their understanding in their
world view that that's troubling you
know
we started off this conversation about
you know Lieutenant mastriana serving on
the Iron Curtain you know defending
against that that the Godless system
that Ronald Reagan described
and that in those days they're in a
Soviet Empire of course schools were
used to indoctrinate to socialize and
indoctrinate according to the edicts of
the rulers and uh that's and I remember
being I'm so glad it's not like that in
America but we're seeing that coming
here in America are you familiar with
ESG I am so that's uh I I view that as
like the Chinese Communist party but for
the the you know the Western version yes
they've got the Chinese Communist party
has an office and all their major
companies so that they have political
control within how with how these
companies operate ESG is basically the
same thing it's a workaround to get
ideology into the business you know what
though I think it's not working
I think we're seeing the backlash there
are many states I think West Virginia
cut ties with uh businesses based on ESG
what was the story you want to pull that
one up yeah I think we talked about it
recently they said that they wouldn't do
business with a specific company based
on their idea uh penalizes major
companies for embracing ESG West
Virginia did that there you go about
four months ago do does the governor
have the authority would you be
interested in this yes yes I do and we
do need to elect a republican General
Assembly that's just a constitutional
Factor but to me together with the
Republican General Assembly there we can
cut off ties with businesses or not
invest in China Russia or companies that
work against our ideas and ideals I
wonder if that same goes for free speech
supporting the First Amendment and
social media companies that take control
of the commons since I've been on the
receiving end you know much as you guys
have been on some of the censorship here
which is just repugnant to me you know
who's deciding what right and wrong is
on some of these issues we've debated
over the past couple years which you
won't bring up because we're going to be
banned on some of the platforms
ironically but I have introduced
legislation I would make it out these
these social media platforms culpable
and subject to being sued by citizens in
Pennsylvania if that passes obviously
I'll sign into law and that they they
cannot screen speech that they just
don't simply like that's basically what
they do I get my thoughts are that we
need to force these companies to free
their software code so that other
developers can pick up like a copy of
Twitter and launch their own Twitter
that they then interoperate because if
you start telling private companies what
they have to do it feels like bashes
like it's like I don't want the
government
but but if people don't like Twitter's
terms of service because they're getting
banned they go to the other Twitter and
then they can still view you you've
swayed me halfway in excellent I don't
agree with this idea of so here's here's
how I view it you free the software code
basically you make the code for the
program available to everybody to make
their own I don't like that it's kind of
like if you build something then
someone's allowed to take copy off your
work and that's like an IP and copyright
thing however I still think freeing the
code is something we probably have to do
because of the algorithms yeah because
we don't know how Facebook is
experimenting on us and we know they do
so this was a big story Facebook
actually was experimenting on people
they were purposefully sending happy
content and hurtful content to people to
see how they would react and sure enough
when they flooded someone's fee with the
pressing content they became depressed
that is psychotic well they were
launching psychological experiments on
unsuspecting users who didn't know that
they were participating in a program
that manipulated the algorithm to see
how they can manipulate their emotions
so that's some larger psychological
warfare that's happening that of course
they're they're seeing what they could
get away with they're seeing how far
they could manipulate a human being if
you can make someone feel sad you can
make someone believe a particular idea
that's god-like power and authority that
I think should be absolutely put in
check and I I kind of agree with Tim
more than I do with Ian him with Ian
because we need to understand what's
happening behind the scenes what is in
the algorithm who's being promoted who's
being demoted who's getting a fair share
of viewership whose ideas are being
shared which ideas are being censored
and more importantly make the code of
conduct simple and enforceable don't
make it vague don't make it General
don't punish people don't delete their
livelihood don't take them away from the
market of of ideas just because they
expressed an idea and you're going to
use an overall vague term in order to
destroy their ability to communicate
that is Draconian that is evil and a lot
of these companies have ties to
governments ties to intelligence
agencies especially with their start so
how do you tackle that as a governor
that's that's a hard question yeah and
there's not an easy solution is that you
know Ian I mean it's a tough one know we
want to protect Free Speech clearly we
want to have a free exchange of ideas
and we've been clamped down in so many
areas you know we can not even mention
all the topics people know what they are
but at what point you know when they
start threatening violence what have you
as we see as we've seen before you know
who who determines where the line is I
mean it was so much easier when we were
growing up I mean free speech if if you
said something to someone that they
didn't like they you duke it out you
just punch each other you know then it's
resolved on the spot for instance Ethan
Klein just got banned off YouTube uh
seven day ban or something for saying
that he thought Ben shapir should be
what gassed I think well if there was he
said if they if there is another kind of
Holocaust that he hopes that's the first
one and it was a joke but it was a very
poorly veiled joke and it was sort of
like not a direct call to violence it's
not illegal because it's not um you know
what do they call it when it's like you
need a time and a place you say it
should happen on this time it's in this
place that's illegal that's imminent it
wasn't an imminent threat but these
these veiled threats are enough for
social media company these a lot of
times in their terms to be like that's
not allowed here I don't agree I think
it's it's First Amendment protected
speech it is violent it can incite
violence though so that's a problem well
look look I wanna I wanna just address
this one just a little bit we didn't get
into it but I don't think Ethan Klein
should have been suspended uh I even
said it the other day when we went over
the comments in the first place but the
fact that he's trying to claim it's a
joke it's like dude you should have said
it was a joke after he said it right in
the same way man if you're gonna do a
joke like that he said at first he said
it was a joke before he was even allowed
to say it before his team like
immediately kind of shut him down so
yeah right but my point is like when you
when you hate someone and insult them
and rag on them No One's Gonna accept it
as a joke right it's just not like if I
came out and said something like that
about AOC no I'm just kidding man come
on dude we're heavily critical of her I
called her a con artist and a grifter
repeatedly today I wish her nothing but
happiness and a long life because I
don't want I don't want I don't want
pain suffering and violence so I'm not
gonna even joke about it but who would
accept it anyway what was it that there
used to be like FCC regulations that you
couldn't go on ABC News and say
something like that yes and now the FCC
doesn't with it what's that I think I
think a lot of the the restrictions on
the media have been lifted have been
like rules have been changed that's
allowing a lot more of this garbage so
we had a FCC would would say like yeah
it's legal but it's not allowed on the
network but now there's no it's not
allowed on the network talking it's up
to these private First Amendment
companies instead of the FCC it's it's
definitely illegal it's legal to do it
but but whether or not it's righteous I
don't know or or Justified or any of
that
I I air on the side of free speech
personally I but you know if you say
well someone rid me of this priest you
know that's and then the priest gets
killed yeah like yeah I don't think you
should I don't think that should be
banned I don't think what Ethan Klein
said should get him banned I think we
should all get to hear it and then be
like wow that was gross you know but if
he if he thinks it's a joke and he
thinks it's funny that's fine I kind of
think that
you know look people jokes I'm not gonna
I'm not gonna get a comedian fired
because he said he's had jokes I don't
like I'm just gonna be like oh watch
something else that's that's the thing I
think I don't think they understand
right now Ethan's you know attacking or
being very critical of Ben Shapiro
because Ben said if another Holocaust
happens I hope Ethan and his family
Escape but that's just me and then he's
like you know these fascists they don't
get it blah blah blah and I'm like dude
when the people on the left say that we
should ban comedians censor people and
shut them down that's extremism that's
authoritarianism yeah I don't think
y'all should be banned because it's
simple I'm an adult and I'll be like
I'll watch something else
he's a comedian he's not funny because
he says mean things about me it's like
okay I'll just watch something else I
co-founded mines The Social Network
minds and uh it's basically First
Amendment it's it's whatever's legal in
Connecticut is legal on the site you
have weird rules like spam which don't
exist in the in the Constitution that
you've got to kind of make but I yeah
there's there's interesting things
um doxing for instance yes that's First
Amendment protected but I don't think it
should be allowed yeah I agree but that
that's a challenge though then right
because if you want to uphold the First
Amendment people are allowed to hold up
your address on a on a placard I mean
the White Pages used to do it now we try
to keep it a little bit more private so
what do you do
I just think I I think it's there's one
rule I'm like yeah doxing you know we
can ban that yeah all right definitely
on a slippery slope here you know and
it's happened so quickly to us since
2020. this is why I like the idea of
freeing the code because I want to leave
the decision up to the uh Network
creators of if they want to ban doxing
on their Network or not right we just
gotta find where free the code doesn't
mean like give out your IP and all the
information all the you know the
intellectual property you've actually
done in writing that code there has to
be a line where it depends on what kind
of business you are I think I think it
depends on what kind of you know we've
talked about this too with um with like
whether Twitter is a platform whether
it's a it's publishing this information
I don't know it has to be discussed as
we worked out because that should it
should be a platform it should be like a
phone company and the the tweets should
be on me not have nothing to do with
Twitter right that's why we need to I
hope when Elon buys this I hope he just
decentralizes the whole thing and just
as like I no longer have the ability to
ban anybody bye have a nice day that'd
be fantastic yeah he'd definitely make
Twitter great again
well I think one of the challenges to be
realistic is you know people can create
fake accounts and then spam the platform
with garbage so and they can do illegal
stuff too well then that's that's that's
the cops problem but if if you're a
network owner and someone puts something
illegal up and you don't immediately
remove it you're complicit in
decentralizes it like I said if Elon
removes his ability by putting Twitter
out as a decentralized system and he
just has Twitter no longer has the
ability to ban accounts like it's hosted
on other servers and people can host
their own servers he like federates it
or something yeah then it's that person
yeah yeah right then the police can go
to you yeah I mean look dude if you go
out in the street and stand if you go if
you go into a hotel and start screaming
racist things they're not going to come
and shut down the hotel
yeah like oh the hotel is hosting this
this offensive speech let's say you say
you you go in there and cite violence
not going to go in the hotel and be like
well you know it was in your space so
you're in trouble no they're gonna
arrest you yeah so that that's the way
it should be if you go onto Twitter and
you say this stuff Twitter should be
like help police there's a guy on our
platform doing saying inciting violence
and committing crime that's how mines
does it right now there you go yeah man
simple as that good there you go with
that all right how about how about this
let's go to super chats if you haven't
already would you kindly smash that like
button subscribe to this Channel and
share the show with your friends become
a member at timcast.com to check out the
cast Castle Vlog Tales from the inverted
world and our uncensored members only
show we have those up Monday through
Thursday at 11 p.m We're not gonna have
one for you tonight unfortunately we
don't have enough time and we're uh
we're just strapped so my apologies
there but we've got a huge Library a ton
of really really awesome people and we
just put out a really uh funny episode
of cast Castle you want to check that
one out and uh share the show if you
like it be the notification help us get
past that censorship let's read some
super chats we got Raymond g Stanley Jr
he says Doug I never realized how big of
a deal PA is in the grand scheme of
things with elections sir when you win
please be level-headed for many of us
just want someone who cares about the
people
he will
I will keep an eye on him
all right I think it speaks the motive
which I already went over here it could
have written off in the sunset
comfortable retirement kernel
strategists author professor of the war
College all the credentials I needed to
do easy things in life what do you think
Shapiro's motivation is a power he wants
to be the first Jewish president of the
United States that he said that oh wow
it's not me saying it so that's not an
anti-semitic right and see how stupid
things are going the mere fact that I
point out that I'm a big advocate of
school choice obviously
twenty thousand dollars a year we're
spending on per student Pennsylvania and
you can't pick your doom to a zip code
in Philadelphia why you vote in Democrat
you're stuck in that school and your
kids are you know flailing but the mere
fact that I point out that he's for
school choice for himself and is able to
afford a very expensive school about 4
30 kids 34 to 40 000 per kid for kids
and that becomes anti-semitic that's how
ridiculous the media has become in
America and in Pennsylvania specifically
they've become ridiculous let's have a
debate let's talk about school choice
and why for the Obamas he could afford a
a very expensive school for his his
daughters in Washington DC but what
about the the rest of the kids in
Washington DC why don't they have that
same right to choose a school this is
the reason why they don't he won't
debate you this this is why this is why
many of these leftists won't come on a
show like this is because we won't pull
a gotcha we'll simply ask hey how come
how come uh these guys there these
people are opposed to school choice but
they send their kids to these expensive
you know charter schools and private
schools and they'll no answer
you know because because you know the
way I see it is you've got a poor kid in
Chicago and in a crummy zip code with
school choice they can go to the really
nice areas and go to the nice School
that's right the only person who who
would have a problem with that is going
to be a wealthy individual who thinks
they're better off and and should be
that that's what we're seeing the
Democratic party has become the party of
the wealthy and you know Tulsi Gabba's
speech that she can no longer be part of
this Elite cabal the Democrat Party
exactly says that should you have
something there no I'm just gonna say
they're they're and the thing is it's
not the average Democrat it's it's sadly
an elite class and sadly there are Elite
Republicans too oh yeah so the blue is
the bluest areas in our state is
Philadelphia that's as blue as you can
get Democrat wise but yeah but despite
that 88 percent of the parents agree
with me on school choice and disagree
with Josh Shapiro wow they want school
choice let's read some more we got none
your business he says Tim do you read
Super Chat starting from the beginning
of the stream or starting from the point
during the stream at which you start
reading super chats from the beginning
so once we go to super chats I go back
to the beginning of all the chats and
then start going through them Destiny
troll says bring back Sheamus Sheamus
for president 2024. oh and a little
Shamrock
uh yeah Sheamus disappeared yeah you
don't have to bring him back it's fine
he reappeared on Twitter last night to
confirm that it was him that made that
quote from Jezebel I don't know if you
guys saw it left this leftist media
attributed a quote from Catholic
conservative Sheamus to Ian who is just
wants to legalize Whedon Pennsylvania oh
you guys how do you feel about
legalizing pot not for recreational use
it's medically legal right now it is
medically legal right now so and so let
me back up the argument because
obviously you're a Libertarian I presume
yes I don't know sometimes it depends on
the leftist authoritarian yeah right and
those labels are always dangerous anyway
because we're all you know free thinkers
but I I looked at what happened in
Washington state Oregon New Mexico and
Colorado and they were promised you know
great revenues with Taxation and but but
we've seen actually a 30 increase in
crimes you know gateways all the stuff
we were warned about actually came true
in those four states I just mentioned
I've been studying the topic there so I
I'm not for recreational use
we'll read some more I I think actually
that was a super chat someone asked that
so Azalea Primrose says Russian doesn't
need to fire nukes at us they will label
them Fentanyl and walk them across the
border bet some are already here scary
stuff I mean that's an interesting point
too people are are very scared of
conventional Warfare when the reality is
our porous border and you know lack our
weak military
it very well may be that Russia uh we
had one guy and say Russia will at least
release a bio weapon or how about China
just sends uh opiates over the Border
that's what they've been doing right man
they've seen so much over the water in
California we're the fourth highest in
fentanyl deaths in the nation 12 to 15
pennsylvanians are dying a day I believe
and Josh up here is doing nothing about
it and most of it was coming from China
yeah all right the Hazmat two to one
says Tim long time listener I took your
advice to heart and I got a 74 acre
parcel in PA after fleeing New Jersey to
live off-grid with my newly wed wife we
don't want PA to become the next New
Jersey and support Doug wholeheartedly
PA needs him that's awesome 74 Acres wow
yeah you guys welcome you know that's a
beautiful thing I'm so pleased to read
that you know you left New Jersey
because of failed Democrat policies and
you're coming to a state that needs to
be Republican and free and not bring in
those failed politics with you do you
guys have animals chickens goats we do
we have we're cat people yeah we like
dogs too oh okay but yeah we're not
we're not allowed to have other animals
oh okay so you don't have chickens no
we're actually not allowed in the we're
next we're next to a state forest and so
they limit
um sadly in our house but our neighbors
are turkeys and deer yeah yeah we do
have to bear we have bear on our front
porch sometimes so that sounds actually
kind of scary
but you're armed right of course yeah oh
yeah well then it's all right we had a
bear come on our front porch uh last
winter I think it was desperate yep and
it tried ripping uh so we have chicken
City I don't know if you saw it's the
big chicken coop we had a smaller one
and we came out one day and the metal
had been pulled and but it didn't get in
because we did triple layer but we had
it on camera a bear was trying to break
in and get the chickens you guys see
that video of the the hiker that the
bear attacked and like Dove at the guy
and he threw it like over his shoulder I
mean have you seen this video
yeah yeah I just saw it today that was
insane and the bear kept coming back
yeah
that's like a horror movie all right
let's read this one from uh a name I
can't read he says Tim I was going to
become a 1 000 a month member for the
next 84 years but then I read Jezebel
about Ian being a conservative so I
decided not to oh well that's awesome 84
000 what is that a thousand dollars uh
so what's what's uh 12 000 times 84.
that's a lot of money yeah that's a lot
of thousands that's uh it's about 900 is
that 10 million thousand yeah I think
it's closer to one million one million
maybe I'm doing the wrong maybe I'm
doing the math 12 12 000 times 84 is
that a million no that's like 100 that's
like one million one million dollars
yeah oh man we lost a million bucks yeah
there it is
all right all right Clayton Johnston
says IRS already making claims about
owing for previous years I just got my
letter a couple days ago saying I owe
them more more for 2020 voting red in PA
see this is what people don't understand
when the Biden Administration uh the
Democrats are bringing on these these
IRS agents we get a conservative talking
point they're going to start auditing
poor people and I said no they aren't
that's ridiculous they're not going to
audit you they're just going to come and
Bill you they don't need to they don't
need you to justify why you owe the
money they're gonna say you owe us the
money now I hope I hope regular people
recognize that yeah because this is what
that's what Clayton's saying uh I see
this personally my family sees it
you will one day get a letter in the
mail and we'll say you owe us 75 bucks
and you'll go for what and it's not
going to tell you you just got to pay it
up
congratulations they're coming for you
they're they're coming they're they're
they're taxing you man it's gonna happen
all right
let's see what we got here
Mike okay Mr Hunt first name Mike nice
try says how are we just watching the
U.S enter an era of World War III
holiday more scenario and not seriously
considering seceding from Blue States
why can't you and other media entities
actively as a group start a movement for
Statewide peaceful secession well we
know I know Luke's talked about peaceful
divorce I know Michael malice has but I
think we're trying as desperately as
possible to not have that happen and
we're hoping that with like a midterm
and then a 2024 election we can actually
just win a culture war and stop the
country from falling apart I think can I
interject something here so during the
shutdown a lot of people get very
aggravated and actually say some you
know pretty potentially violent things
about how frustrated they are with the
government and then I would ask them the
question they're like well did you vote
in the last election no did you vote in
the presidential no I'm like then you're
part of the problem so secession is I'm
going to say a ridiculous idea we
resolve this at The Ballot Box and let's
do it this way you know go out and vote
and be active and if you're really that
serious about it and it sounds like he's
pretty passionate about it then
volunteer for a campaign donate to a
campaign or maybe run for office
yourself instead of talking so you know
uh bombastically we'll be a poll Watcher
well personally I think secession
session isn't a great idea when you see
it from a point of view of
decentralization uh from the point of
view of how the Amish have done it from
the point of view of individuals taking
personal responsibility for themselves
we might be at odds here but that's how
I see it and I think it's a great idea
that we should strive for on an
independent local level it's such a
Convention of states too how does that
work is that between Governors or
between State legislation that would be
through state legislators selecting
representatives to represent a state in
a Convention of states and then
obviously um it's coming out of the
conservative movement but there's also
fears on the Second Amendment side that
that could be it could be a runaway
convention that could start infringing
upon our rights and that might be
another way to circumvent the
Constitutional process you know
individually the Amish still pay their
taxes they still obey our laws and what
have you so even though they have their
own schools they still have to pay
school tax too yes you know like that's
that seems ridiculous but a fracturing
at the greater level like I'm thinking
1861 I don't want him maybe you know
without the conflict but I don't want to
see that happen to our country we're
better off as a United States of America
yeah we just got to win people need to
get out and vote you know they still to
this day Doug you know elections in
Pennsylvania are compromise I don't know
if I'm going to go are you kidding me
then that's exactly Democrats want you
to help they want you to stay home we
there's so many Republicans that don't
vote I mean The Inquirer actually wrote
an article they're concerned they're
seen as red wave of Robbie and I
traveling across the state getting these
massive crowds in rural counties and
they're like wow if those Republicans
actually go out and vote Madison is
going to win so yes get out and vote and
go knock on your neighbor's doors yes
call your friends call your family and
say we got to do this yeah and take the
Amish to the polls that's right they
drive them to the polls we have a lot a
lot of support in the Amish community we
do is that so well all right we got
Morgan mogas he says hey Tim big fan of
the show if Josh Shapiro keeps avoiding
Doug's debate calls he should debate
mises caucus libertarian candidate Matt
Hackenberg instead it would really make
Josh look cowardly there's a lot of
people here's my first thoughts on this
question obviously a lot of people who
are Libertarians we have a lot of music
caucus and libertarian friends they want
to be contenders in this they want to
make sure people recognize them and so I
see a lot of people being like you know
you should debate the libertarian but
they actually make an interesting point
here that I thought it really would make
Josh apparel look cowardly if you
excluded him and the conversation
shifted away from Democrats into
something totally different you know
what I mean yeah that's interesting or
just simply put it like you're hosting a
debate for the governorship and
everyone's invited who's running for
government and would you debate a
Libertarian candidate yeah let me eat
anyone I mean we have a green candidate
out there I don't know why we're not
talking about her as well who is that I
I don't have her name handy but she made
it on the ballot and she's a viable
alternative to Josh Shapiro that's for
sure if you don't want to vote red yeah
I was we were talking with some of the
you know uh I think it was when Dave
Smith was here he he's a music caucus
guy and and um we're good friends we're
big fans but I gotta say look man I
don't I don't I don't view the the new
Maga Republican uh uh America First
types as the lesser of two evils the way
I've I viewed The Establishment
Republican party I certainly don't agree
with everything the Republican party has
to offer but there's a handful of
Republicans where I'm like yeah they're
actually pretty good school choice is a
good thing like I agree with these
things they don't want war I'm like you
won me over with that you want school
choice I actually see an opportunity now
within the Republican party with many
candidates to actually get some good
people in I think the Republicans got to
do a lot to get rid of that Old Guard
garbage you know uh establishment stuff
but you know to our libertarian friends
the risk that everyone sees is
are you going to split the vote is it
going to end up hurting everybody if if
we if we try and go for the the cream of
the crop utopian Vision or do we say hey
look we got some pretty good guys right
here how do you I don't know man I don't
have any answers that's tough and that's
hurt us before the reason why and
whatever we think of bush the Elder is
irrelevant to my point but Perot came in
and he insured a Clinton Victory which
can a transition in our country
culturally I do think it would be
hilarious and I understand the political
uh challenge but it would be hilarious
if if you guys just organized the
governorship debate and put his Podium
up there and just there you go we could
have a we can have a cup
and we could even make him you know a
little bigger than the life
I mean look you invite the Green Party
candidate too let them represent the
left and then be like why is is he
refusing to show up and actually speak
to you I don't think you would have an
idea I don't think you'd mention him at
that point just call it the 2022
Pennsylvania Governor
whoever comes invite everyone who's
running officially on the ballot
he could bring Donna Brazil with him who
of course who cheated famously in 2016
gave Hillary all the questions before
the debate uh he I'll even give him a
box to stand on so he looks taller it's
okay Josh I'll see you on the debate
floor man do you guys know each other
personally not at all we saw them one
time and he screwed it away from us up
in Erie oh wow
all right let's see we can grab here
Teddy here says third ID 123rd Signal
Battalion Echo company 98.99 godspeed
mastriano voice of the Marnie we uh yeah
we did we overlap with yeah we overlap I
was in the third infantry division
division artillery from
1997. no 98. 98 to 2000 yeah it was 90.
is that some kind of MK Ultra activation
code that's what I'm getting from I'm
like I'm a civilian I don't know what
you guys are saying there but I'm
concerned we're rocking the barn because
in 1918 when the Germans broke through
the French lines uh my unit stood like a
rock on the Martin River and stopped
them wow all right Isaac Glover show
says can Mr mastriano please consider
joining the new Trump Administration in
2024 if he loses his Governor's race
also can't wait to see Carrie Lake win
uh we're gonna win bigly at the borrow
from Donald Trump so hopefully but thank
you for thinking so much in me I I yeah
and also Carrie Lake man I I've seen
more and more of her videos I really
think she could be president yeah she's
she's fantastic the look I have
tremendous respect for anybody who can
come here and sit and have a
conversation with us you know because
some people a lot of politicians they
can't even debate yeah it's like do you
really have ideas if you don't know
anything about those ideas you can't
back them up yeah that's true I don't
know man look I can disagree with you or
anybody else but as long as you know why
you think something I'll be like okay
well you know you know you mentioned
some things uh on the show about your
policies and I'm like I actually don't
know enough to refute what you're saying
I'm not going to argue about something I
don't know just for the sake of politics
so at least you know there you go well
thank you for being a decent journalist
in that regard there
yeah you know we we we all deal with how
they lie all day and night I mean look
like we were mentioning they called Ian
Crossland a conservative commentator
they call me a conservative and like
none of it is just it's just meaningless
yeah they call all of us conservatives
it's like that's just nonsense I mean
anybody who's ever heard anything out of
Ian's mouth would laugh at the idea of
him being called a conservative you know
what happened what caused that I think
I've been tilting conservative since
I've been here uh no they thought I was
Sheamus Coughlin they they quoted a
different guy and thought
on the show I don't know it's like they
didn't want it's like they got an AI
transcript of it they don't do the work
they don't do the work it's a Google
search yeah I don't know I think of
myself as liberally conservative or
conservatively liberal now if they're
getting your name wrong imagine what
else they're getting wrong and all the
articles that they put out there
all right Ashley B yo says first Super
Chat super pumped to see mastriano
no notification tonight on here I live
right outside of Scranton big props for
coming on and God bless
this is what uh you know these are the
kind of kind of shows that we need more
of not the sound bites you appear on The
Primetime show for five minutes long
form it's really it's really hard to lay
out a solid policy position in five
minutes or less yeah impossible I start
talking fast because I'm gonna squeeze
it in it's like it doesn't even flow and
I appreciate it music slowly gets louder
and louder
thanks for coming on quick
Nick colinello says my fiance and I are
hoping to have kids in the future what
goals do you have for Pennsylvania's
Department of Education in four or five
years wow it's going to be rapid changes
because it's our department of education
has become very radicalized we've
covered some of the books you have the
books there and it's discussing so we're
on the on day one CRT is over on day one
no more gender program pronoun games on
this is all 17 January on day one uh
we'll be reaffirming Toronto rights and
I even have to say that I kind of Choke
On It in America really no kidding and
then I'll back all these up with
legislation out of the House and Senate
I'm not going to rule by edict but I'm
going to change the culture on day one
uh have a secretary of education that'll
be focused on education and not
indoctrination that means we need to
have all the curriculum posted online
for parental review and transparency so
there'll be uh this this school
districts will be ordered to post that
that was a bill by the way vetoed by
Governor wolf a couple months ago
transparency in the curriculum you know
I think the more eyes that are on things
the better off we are the more
accountability for public we're spending
31 billion dollars a year in
Pennsylvania on education according to a
2020 report from the National Education
Association we are the 12th highest in
the nation spending wise with 28th and
quality student before covid we're not
getting our bang for the buck and so my
goal is actually to do education rather
than indoctrination and history Civics
and Constitution to be brought back
right on you know that's from a doctor
in history by the way he's taught at the
Master's Degree level cares about
education I believe in our history and
our in our laws people need to read the
Constitution and study it
um agreed I see and you know granted you
know I came in with a framework and
understanding Constitution but being in
the Pennsylvania Senate during the
shutdown during Cove it was a crash
course in the Constitution I I had no
idea things were happening so rapidly
and much of it was because of ignorance
of the laws and the rules and and our
basic constitutional rights that people
have seen that not have a grasp of
anymore that's right be cool if little
kids in like Elementary School learn how
to write a bill and and pass it with the
other kids could vote on it and then
like change it or find it in the
classroom yeah write a check or we don't
write checks too much
you know kids not knowing how how the
financial system or the business or the
economy works oh yeah compound interest
taxes at all yeah and that would be so
easy to do that to have a mock-up of a
house and send it and the governor and
it's so fun well the good schools have
to change roles every few months or
every month they're really expensive
private schools have things like this
that's right class president stuff like
that the the public schools they just
leave you high and drive yeah all right
hexagon proton says one of my co-workers
used to work in mining and at activists
lock themselves to Machinery overnight
one day they left them there through the
day sitting in the sun for nine hours
they didn't return did you guys see
these uh so first there was the the two
women who threw the tomato soup on the
on the van Gogh that's disgusting yeah
then they glued their hands to the wall
immediately got arrested I was outraged
they should have left them there yeah
yeah you glue yourself to the wall you
become the exhibit and then when you
gotta go to the bathroom you can beg for
help and we'll say no out there was a
now there's a bunch of uh scientists I
think it's in Germany they glued
themselves to the floor of this Porsche
showroom
and then they got really mad that uh no
it was VW yeah VW wouldn't give them
bedpans
because they were like how are we
supposed to respect you know uh
respectfully defecate now that we glued
ourselves to the floor and my attitude
was like I don't know he's planning
failure to plan is planning for failure
bro personal problems should have
brought one with them
I I love peaceful protest it's fantastic
America has has done great things with
peaceful protests and uh if you want to
peacefully protest I respect it but you
pay the consequences you block a street
you get arrested but you did something
that wasn't hurting people in in a great
degree I understand there can be
problems like you know if a car can't
get through and someone loses their job
or there's a lot of problems there but
that's why you get arrested for it you
should block the road the cops should
come and arrest you you get the Press
everybody understands we need some
wiggle room with civil disobedience that
also means though if you lock yourself
to a door you better be prepared to crap
on the floor if you're not thinking
about this stuff I want to tell you
all right Dylan Lolly says
using my first Tim cast Super Chat to
say one thing to my future Governor
constitutional carry oh yeah I love it
it's gonna happen more constitutional
carry everywhere it's amazing looking at
the map of the United States and the
expansion of constitutional carry Second
Amendment is winning because for a long
time they did not respect it a lot of
people uh bro Cody said also ask about
constitutional carry I think we
understand you are very much for it
that's what I was curious about
gen Z says Doug has my vote but will he
repeal gun laws like permitted carry and
fight the feds when they overstep
already answered it actually have a bill
in in the Senate to do just that wow all
right uh I'm gonna read this one it's a
bit more extreme though Lima x-ray says
will you declare the ATF a terrorist
organization like your libertarian
opponent met Hackenberg
I don't know if that I mean I don't know
yeah I think my simple answer is I I
would be for abolishing it I think the
the duties they do can easily be handled
by any law enforcement already we don't
need or create an ATF free zone
or or make it make it into a convenience
store even better oh yeah can a governor
declare groups as a terrorist group no
especially a federal law enforcement
agency
I'm still waiting well I mean I'm sure
the libertarian actually is saying that
but it's like come on you know and
that's the thing that drives me crazy
about politics people say anything to
get a vote and that's why you know the
senate race is interesting and it's a
lot about you know Law and Order and
crime as I mentioned before but there's
nothing that they can do about Law and
Order and crime at the state level that
that's a state issue anyway all right
piano's helicopter tour says so Tim
you're telling me the guy who smoked
shredded parmesan floor cheese has
committed 459 crimes and the big guy Joe
was not involved in one I didn't say
that I believe he's probably involved in
a bunch of them you know uh he did try
to smoke parmesan cheese I do remember
that yeah that's a fact I mean but
that's sad man yeah it's it's I feel bad
for Hunter that's like I think he's a
bad guy I think he's done bad things but
hearing a story like that is just like
like Rock Bottom points this is true
yeah yeah he was he was he was crack
he's a crack he was a crack addict I
know what you're still doing and so in
his desperation he grabbed parmesan
cheese and put it in his pipe I guess
and probably more cheese I mean look
I don't want to rag on the difficulties
faced by an individual but come on the
Biden family has serious issues and
there's there's reasons why a person
ends up that way yeah you know I I know
it's not it's not always true of every
parent some parents try really hard and
some somehow their kids fall into bad
stuff for sure but uh you know
the fact that Hunter Biden was working
on on stuff related to Joe's work and
stuff like that come on you got to be
more responsible there
all right all right let's grab some
Super Chips let's try and find a good
one what do we got
uh hops it up says Tim and crew what's
your take on businesses being sued for
not rendering services to LGBT plus what
if the business would just charge a
crazy amount of money for cake photos
Etc wouldn't lawsuit not be valid that's
interesting uh this is this is a tough
question I mean how do you solve for
this you're aware what's going on with
the the Colorado Baker yes that he you
know he he had no he said he had no
problem giving a cake song a cake to a
gay wedding it said he didn't want to
make a custom message about supporting
it well now he's been sued several times
I'm curious you know how do you solve
for this look the law says you can't
discriminate on the basis of you know
these these idea well I should say
national origin gender gender identity
what are your thoughts on this how do
you how do you yeah I don't know I don't
know how do you solve for that yeah
that's just a tough one I mean we've got
so many great areas in our country now
you know I I don't believe that you if
you have a objection to something why
can't you just say I'm sorry you know
and I know in the case of the Florida
she recommended another
florist for a wedding and that wasn't
good enough it's not good enough they
want you to do they want you to do it
this is a dangerous Trend here when you
know if you have an objection to
something why what happened to your own
rights I mean it's I I wonder if if
scale is the answer if it's a small
business where it's like one person you
should be able to bring an action but if
it's like a chain or or a dominant
business and you can prove that they've
monopolized a certain area or something
like that then you can that might be
like if it's a public corporation well
no I mean like if you're if you're a
single individual who has a storefront
selling flowers and you say I'm not
gonna do business with you it should be
like carry on and move on so you can
find flowers anywhere but if it's
Walmart they shouldn't be able to turn
you away because they've they've
dominated monopolized such a large
portion that you can't really go
anywhere else wow can I give a shout out
Josh French served with me in
Afghanistan Josh I love you brother oh
he says sure those that Colonel mastrano
respect him those that don't know him
should oh those that know him respect
him those who don't should hey guys I
love you man he was a great member of
our team in Afghanistan right on oh yeah
yeah all right let's see let's try and
find a good one because we only got a
little bit of time left
you know I'll I'll say this just as I'm
kind of trying to read and speak at the
same time I do try to find good
questions especially hard ones but when
a good portion of all of the super chats
are just outright love you big fan you
know go mastriano and things like that
it's like you know there's all I can't
just sit here for 10 minutes trying to
find everything
but uh let's see if we can uh I'll just
try and make sure I can find one more
just a good one that we can uh we can
end off with
otherwise I'll just grab what I see
coming up soon
all right
all right I'm just gonna have to they're
all they're all just big fans of yours
yeah so that'll all look like that
everybody's just being like Doug you
rock can't wait to vote for you so yeah
pretty much I'm like where's the person
who's got a question about policy that
but all right zero says Mass General
kept me sane during the abuse of power
from the Democrats during coven watching
his Fireside Chats gave me hope can't
wait to vote for you yeah the one thing
I I you know I know that there was there
was a a lot of q a sessions with
politicians in the past and they always
do pre-screened questions we don't do
that no but at the same time hey guys
you know I always try to find good ones
but uh everybody's just saying they love
you so I guess that's what that's what
you get love you guys back uh so my
friends if you haven't already would you
kindly smash that like button subscribe
to this Channel and share the show with
your friends become a member at
timcast.com to support all of our work
you can follow the show at timcast IRL
you can follow me at timcast Senator
mastriano do you want to shout anything
out
well you know what Pennsylvania is the
birthplace of our country is founded by
William Penn who of course is escaped uh
persecution for his own faith and um he
founded our state with the idea that all
men can be freak people and live their
lives as they saw fit not as a governor
or magistrator or King Sol fit and that
shaped our government I think we have to
remember who we are we are the
birthplace of freedom and liberty
or the same state of course her new
birth of Freedom was secured at
Gettysburg and then finally 2001 on 9 11
and that dark day the only hope was
flight 93 and although it had a tragic
ending remember what Todd Beamer said
let's Roll so Pennsylvania and America
let's roll on eight November you got a
website go to dougfergov.com
all right they're ready you want
anything today I just would like to say
you know we are the Keystone State so
um the governor's race is important to
all of the USA because of holding
together that that Arch that Keystone
holds together the rest and I really
think that the way that Pennsylvania
goes is going to be the way the nation
goes right on if you guys get elected I
want some PBA cards uh thank you guys
for coming on I didn't always agree with
everything but at least we had the
conversation thank you so much for that
uh my YouTube channel and news in the
organization is we are change.org I did
a very in-depth look into the false flag
allegations by the United States a deep
dive into some very serious issues if
you want to see that video you can right
now on youtube.com forward slash we are
change thank you so much for having me
good talking to you guys good talking
next time maybe we'll go deeper on some
conspiracy theories like talking plasma
that the military might be using to make
us think there are aliens and I hope to
work with you in the governor's office
at some point with technology
because people have something to live
for and they want to and they will I'd
love Pennsylvania innovate and lead in
that technology would be fantastic love
you sir love you guys thank you right on
guys I think you should check out cast
Castle is really funny by the way Ann I
watched today I don't normally watch it
but it was good I also watch your video
on YouTube today because I saw it on my
recommended switch I recommend for some
stuff but I guess not Tim cast and oh
you got Luke got recommendations right
yeah yeah I'm moving on up yeah guys and
I am in the chat that is me the
iamsearch.com you can find me everywhere
that again I'm in there with you
commenting whatever yeah yeah right
we're having a lot of fun I was going
see you guys it'd be funny to do a skit
where it's like 10 years from now and
it's this futuristic world of flying
cars and Ian's like you know a little
bit older and he's looking at a picture
of of Doug over here and then he's like
and then he looks up at a statue of him
and it says he created the first
graphene plan revolutionizing technology
yeah yeah we did it like we could build
a campus where people learn to come
all right everybody thanks for hanging
out we're not having a members only show
because we just we don't really have
enough time for it unfortunately but I
do appreciate all of you who our members
help make it all possible and we'll see
you all next time cheers